ich bin vor irgendjemand da kurz was trinken muss ehrlich sagen ich habe die woche gar nicht
mal so viel verfolgt weder was technik sachen angeht noch irgendwie youtube twitch sonst was
weiß ich doch wieder gepieft hat schon oft gesagt jetzt will ich aber schon vorbei zweifelsfall haben
sich wieder die üblichen verdächtigen war die woche irgendwas spannendes so technik mäßig was
ich verpasst habe weil ich muss sagen ich habe also normalerweise lese ich ja immer so ein
bisschen quer von hacker news bis heise und sonstwie aber ich habe mir nichts nichts
großartig angeguckt die woche und meister chat kaputt oder moment das muss jetzt mal
testen da ist leute da noch keiner was geschrieben keck funktioniert
ja
ich habe nichts angeguckt ich habe bestimmt irgendwas verpasst ich war die woche zu sehr
beschäftigt mit neben neben arbeiten gehen ab so ein bisschen rum rennen gehen ich musste
mmo kreise kreisen gab nämlich event diese woche a jetzt okay ich habe nämlich event diese woche
und wir haben sie gewonnen gestern easy also quasi richtig gewonnen wir haben so hoch gewonnen oder so
dass die anderen ausgelockt sind und lieber heartstone gespielt habe
es ist sehr schade dass heise keine oder golem oder wer auch immer für hacker news gab es
früher mal eine ganz gute wochen zusammenfassung gibt es jetzt auch schon eine weile nicht mehr
ich suche schon ich habe das auch schon ein paar mal im stream gesagt ich suche nach einer guten
news zusammenfassung für die woche
ich habe noch keine wirklich gute gefunden die mir gefällt entweder beschäftigt sich mit sich dingen
die mich nicht interessieren oder keine ahnung ist es was sie hat da jemand vielleicht irgendwelche
guten empfehlung oder so ich habe bis jetzt noch nichts gefunden warum habe ich eigentlich immer
noch das windows so auf dem desktop liegen nein ich will nicht updaten weil das neueste
vor allem workstation nämlich im arsch so stream starb immer package updates bis der stream richtig
angelaufen ist irgendwie hat sie das ganze mal nicht verpasst das ist ja immer so aber ich habe
via Twitch gerade noch so ein paar kleine
Startschwierigkeiten. Moin Martin.
Ja.
Machen wir mal Package-Updates, weil
ach, Linux by the way, da gibt es auf jeden Fall
neue Packages. Das ist auch
so ein Ding, was ich nicht verstehe, ist,
viele Leute haben ja unter Linux so einen
grafischen Login-Manager
oder Start,
weiß gar nicht, wie das Ding genau heißt.
Da frage ich mich, warum
einen grafischen Login-Manager,
wenn man doch einfach auch
Kommando-Zeilen-Login machen kann
und an X starten.
The Hacker-Man-Way.
Warum starte ich Firefox? Ich will eigentlich nur Package-Updates
machen. Das updatet eh Firefox
und Kernel und alles nach einer Woche.
Muss ich eh rebooten gleich.
Und was haben wir hier?
Bind, Alter. Warum habe ich überhaupt, wahrscheinlich für
NS-Lookup und so Zeug.
Bin nicht sicher, ob das überhaupt ein Bind-Tool ist.
Vulkan Headers
Wireshark. Ah, okay.
Ne. Doch, doch.
Linux Kernel Update. Okay. Yes.
Lass ich auch noch updaten.
Dann sind Package-Updates
durch.
Ich habe übrigens
ein sehr nice Projekt gefunden.
Auf ShitHub.
Was wir uns heute Mittag im Stream mal angucken werden.
Ich bin ja immer so
auf der Suche
nach neuen
Monitoring-Tools. Sowohl für
das Business-Enterprise-Umfeld
als auch für daheim.
Was es da so gibt. Wir haben ja auch die meisten schon mal uns
bisschen angeguckt.
Ja, ich hänge hier immer noch auf einer ollen Zabbix-Installation
daheim, weil ich das halt irgendwann mal eingerichtet
habe und es funktioniert halt.
Aber ich mag Zabbix auch nicht. Ich mag eigentlich so gut
wie keine Monitoring-Tool.
Das Ding.
Ich habe ein weiches Herz für Nagios,
aber nicht, dass ich es verwenden wollen würde,
sondern einfach nur, weil es das erste
dieser Art ist, was ich benutzt habe und mich
als Azubi damals drum gekümmert habe.
Und ich mag die
Customizability-Möglichkeiten,
die man hat, beispielsweise mit Prometheus.
Aber so der Weisheit
als letzter Schluss ist das alles irgendwie nicht.
Deswegen.
Ich habe was Neues entdeckt.
So nachher mal ausprobieren. Gucken, ob
das taugt. Zwar nennt sich das
Open Observe.
Da sind es anscheinend hauptsächlich
für Anwendungsmonitoring gedacht,
aber nachdem das auch
Prometheus-Metriken und
Open Military Collector Sachen
frisst, kann man das
auch für so gut wie alles andere verwenden.
Das wollte ich schon mal sagen.
Wollen wir mal angucken, ob das taugt.
Immer gut
informt zu sein.
Moin, Rektmann.
So, Package-Updates sind durch.
Hatte ich jetzt eigentlich auch die User-Repost geupdatet.
Gucken wir mal, ob bei Jetbrains
irgendwas Neues da ist.
Machen wir mal komplett Package-Updates überall.
Hat das mal irgendjemand verwendet?
Jetbrains hat ja mittlerweile so tausend
Sachen und
da sind ja auch einige dabei, wo ich mich so frage,
wer und wann verwendet das eigentlich, ja?
Also das da zum Beispiel,
Rightside, keine Ahnung, noch nie installiert,
noch nie geöffnet, noch nie angeguckt.
Aber wir wissen ja, Documentation, ne?
Wer braucht schon Documentation,
wenn die Sachen funktionieren, ne?
Wenn's geht einfach, da muss man auch nichts
dokumentieren, weil wenn's immer geht,
muss auch keiner reparieren und dann
braucht man auch keine Docs.
So, also keine Ahnung, was das hier eigentlich
sein soll, genau. Aqua hab ich auch noch nie
gesehen. IDI for Test,
Automation, warum er eine IDE braucht für
Tests, whatever, keine Ahnung,
Jetbrains, hat bestimmt seinen Sinn.
Wirklich,
ja, checken, warum es da so viele verschiedene
gibt, keine Ahnung.
Ja, Fleet ist auch so ein Ding, das haben sie ja mal
gestartet, vor zig, zig
Jahren, das ist ja auch schon bestimmt drei, vier Jahre alt.
Um mit
Visual Studio Code zu konkurrieren,
hat's bis jetzt nicht geschafft und
ich, ich sehe auch niemand,
der hauptsächlich Fleet verwendet.
Data Spell hab ich auch noch nie verwendet.
Wie gesagt, nur weil ich das nicht verwendet habe,
weiß der nicht, dass es schlecht ist oder so, ja.
Ich frag mich halt nur, wer und wann und wie
verwendet man das und weshalb.
Webstorm,
ja, Webstorm ist
tatsächlich nicht schlecht, Webstorm verwende ich aber nicht.
Verwende ich für Frontend-Sachen, lieber Visual Studio Code.
C-Line verwende ich ab und zu,
PHP-Storm, ja, wenn's sein muss.
Data-Crip, Data-Crip muss tatsächlich
ganz nice sein, glaube ich.
Für alle, die viel mit Datenbank-Krams
hantieren. Ja,
.NET-Profile, das haben wir schon mal, Ruby-Mine
hab ich früher oft das verwendet. Space-Desktop,
das ist, glaube ich, die
Codespace-Alternative,
nee, wie heißt das? Workspace-
Alternative von JetBrains,
auch noch nicht verwendet.
Keine Ahnung, auch so ein Ding,
wer immer auch das verwendet.
Gut, Android Studio, klar, Pyjama,
Gateway, auch keine Ahnung.
Also die Hälfte davon ist so ein Ding, wo ich frag so,
für wen, für was und warum.
So, Reboot.
Jet, was ist mit euch los heute Morgen?
Keiner sagt was.
Alle noch bad ge...
Ja, ist ja auch Aufwachen-Stream.
Da ist es erlaubt.
Gateway ist eigentlich nice.
Ich hab jetzt von der kurzen Übersicht
nicht gecheckt,
was es eigentlich sein soll.
Was hältst du von Grafana? Grafana ist das beste
Visualisierungstool, ganz ehrlich.
Ich hab ein paar andere ausprobiert.
Ich hab, ähm,
Tele, ja, wie heißt das Ding? Nicht Telegraph.
Telegraph, dieses
Chronograph, oder so?
Das InfluxDB.
Das InfluxDB-Ding hab ich ausprobiert.
So, und dann hab ich
noch
das Elasticsearch-Ding ausprobiert.
Ist das Kibana?
Bin mir aus dem Kopf nicht ganz sicher. Ist Kibana, Kibana
das, ähm,
Grafana-Äquivalent von
Elasticsearch geht uns?
Das hab ich auch ausprobiert.
Und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, Grafana,
leider geht mir Grafana
ein bisschen zu sehr in letzter Zeit
in die Richtung. Ja, wir haben coole
Connector und alles, aber das ist
nur noch für Enterprise Edition.
Aber Grafana ist für mich
die beste Mischung aus, man checkt
es relativ easy, wie es funktioniert,
die ganzen Query-Languages
für die unterschiedlichen Sachen, ja,
und dass man auch was Gescheites rauskriegt. Da ist ja
nix wirklich Grafana dran schuld. Das ist, je nachdem
was man fährt, ein bisschen komplizierter.
Okay.
Ähm, aber so, insgesamt finde ich
ist Grafana das Beste aus
Übersichtlichkeit, es ist easy zu
installieren. Letztendlich Grafana glaub ich einfach nur
ein einzelnes Go-Binary.
Man kann es starten, weil die meistens wahrscheinlich
in irgendeinem Docker starten werden.
Im Container starten werden.
Also ich finde Grafana ist das beste
Visualisierungstool, was es gibt.
Deswegen bin ich mal gespannt.
Wir gucken uns heute Mittag mal OpenObserve an.
Da ist alles mit dabei, das ist
ähm, Metering, Logs,
Traces, alles mögliche
mit dabei und das wohl in einer UI
und relativ easy zu starten. Mal
gespannt, ob das taugt. Ja.
Also ich finde Grafana ist das beste Visualisierungstool.
Grafana alleine bringt natürlich auch nix.
Grafana alleine,
da fehlt ihr halt
Warum kann ich meine Session nicht
Restore?
Grafana alleine für Monitoring
ist halt auch nix. Grafana ist nur der
Visualisierungspart.
Also sowohl für
Alerts, als auch für
das Datencollecten an sich
braucht man was. Ja ich weiß Grafana
hat mittlerweile ihr, wie nennt sich das?
Unified
Alerting oder so.
Das habe ich aber
noch nie ausprobiert.
Weiß ich nicht, wie gut oder schlecht das ist. Ich könnte mir
vorstellen, dass das ein bisschen
hakelig ist.
Wenn du mehr machen willst
als Wert
ist über oder Wert ist unter
von irgendwas. Aber weil, keine Ahnung
habe ich noch nie großartig ausprobiert.
Aber ich bin auch der Meinung,
Alert schicken ist gar nicht mal so sehr die Aufgabe
von Grafana.
Ja, ich habe ganz viele Ideen für ein neues
YouTube Video. Oh du Mist, ich habe
eine riesenlange Liste und da kommt
auch immer was dabei. Ich habe sogar auf dem Handy noch eine extra
Liste. Aber
ich habe gerade so irgendwie gar keine
Motivation YouTube zu machen. Ich weiß, das
sackt jetzt für
einige so ein bisschen. Für mich
ja auch.
Übrigens, ich wurde richtig
gebetet. Ich habe hier eine Abrechnung
liegen von meinem
Doktor. Und zwar
hat der
also ich lese
euch das mal vor.
Also Blut abnehmen
kostet 4,19 Euro.
Weil Faktor
1,8. Okay.
So, dann gibt es
ähm
die Sachen, die getestet wurden.
Und dann, und dann kommt's.
Dann hat er noch abgerechnet
Eingangsberatung
10,72 Euro.
Mir ist nicht bewusst, dass
in irgendeiner Art und Weise dort
irgendeine Beratung stattgefunden
hätte.
Ich weiß nicht, auf welche Art
er mich angeblich irgendwie beraten
hat.
Aber kann man natürlich super abrechnen,
ja. Ich meine
10,72 Euro ist jetzt auch nicht so das Ding.
Aber schon ein bisschen
gebetet.
Zabbix. Ja, ich habe daheim
auch ein Zabbix laufen. Aber ich bin, wie gesagt,
ich habe es schon oft gesagt, ich bin mit
keinem Monitoring Tool so richtig
glücklich. Gerade für den Heimbereich nicht.
Heimbereich will ich irgendwas
super easymäßiges haben.
Eine GUI
und darin ein bisschen rumklicken
alles, was ich brauche.
Zabbix ist nur Enterprise 0.
Du kannst auch Zabbix daheim verwenden.
Das Problem an Zabbix ist, dass Zabbix
abartig zu konfigurieren ist über das Webinterface.
Aber immerhin, es ist ein Webinterface
und man kann alles, oder zumindest
99 Prozent,
außer irgendwelche Custom-Check-Definitionen
oder sowas, kann man im
Webinterface machen.
Das ist echt der Vorteil von Zabbix.
Zabbix, muss man aber sagen, ist insgesamt
so als All-in-One-Monitoring-Solution
ein bisschen aus der Zeit gefallen
durch die Architektur.
Glaube ich, ist es zumindest
meine Auffassung des Ganzen, weil
Zabbix selbst
kommt aus einer Zeit,
also ich zeig das mal hier,
Zabbix,
das da meine ich.
Zabbix kommt aus einer Zeit,
da hat man noch,
das ist übrigens, oh Moment, das ist Grafana.
Wollte ich gerade sagen.
Ja, so sieht das
im Endeffekt aus, das Dashboard.
Also, Zabbix kommt aus
einer Zeit, da hat man noch
ganz klassisch, das größte
Teil des Monitorings
damals als Zabbix
entstanden ist, war
klassisches, wir gucken von außen
drauf Monitoring.
Wir gucken, ob ein Service up oder down ist, indem wir checken,
ob ein Port auf ist, ob eine SSH-Verbindung
geht, ob das Ganze pingt,
ob das eine ordentliche Response liefert.
Um Infos von einzelnen
Systemen zu bekommen, hat man eine
Zabbix Agent installieren müssen
und das war es im Endeffekt.
Aus der Zeit kommt Zabbix.
Die Dashboards, die man in Zabbix machen kann,
können auch null, aber wirklich null,
auch wenn man es vielleicht hier auf den ersten Blick nicht sieht,
weil es hier noch ganz hübsch aussieht,
aber die können absolut null
mithalten mit Grafana.
Die sind super hakelig
zum Reinscrollen, Rausscrollen überhaupt
und die Möglichkeiten an
verschiedenen Graphen und wie man das
in der heutigen Zeit ist,
Lichtjahre
hinter Grafana.
Jetzt kommen wieder
die Leute und sagen,
actually Max, Lichtjahre sind Entfernung
und keine Zeit. Ja, ja, ist okay.
Ich wollte das nur
verdeutlichen, wie weit das hinter Grafana ist.
Es gibt immer Leute, die müssen
da mal sowas einhaken. Nein, nein, nein,
ich weiß es aber besser.
Moin Fips.
Ja,
und in der heutigen Zeit ist es
allerdings so, dass man
nicht nur, also wenn es um
Systemüberwachung geht oder generell ums
Überwachen geht, dass man nicht nur
so nennen wir es mal
Blackbox Monitoring machen will, so von
außen gucken, ist Service up, ist Port
offen, ist Ping ja,
ja, nein, Domain löst auf und sowas
oder eben per Agent mit
Sachen collecten will. Heute hast du
noch deutlich mehr. Heute willst
du Anwendungsmetriken
collecten, generell relativ
viele Metriken collecten und wir reden
hier nicht von, ja, einmal
in der Minute einen Ping ausführen und gucken, ob es
funktioniert, sondern wir reden hier teilweise
von tausenden Metriken
pro Sekunde und
das kann entweder durch
Prometheus Collectors passieren oder durch
irgendwelche Exporter in der Anwendung, Open
Telemetry will man auch noch
collecten und
es gibt heute auch noch
die ganze, ja,
Cloud- und Containerwelt, die ihre
unterschiedlichen Endpunkte haben für Monitoring.
Wie man beispielsweise im Kubernetes
Cluster die Workloads überwacht,
du willst ja nicht nur überwachen so, was macht dein
Workload selbst, ja,
du willst ja auch noch überwachen so, was macht
denn der Cluster an sich, hat der noch
genug freie IPs, um neue Workloads
und neue Pods zu schedulen und sowas, willst dir alles
angucken, das heißt, muss auch irgendwie da rein,
war lange nachdem Zabbix erfunden
wurde, dann willst du heute mittlerweile
eigentlich auch im gleichen Monitoring
Tools zumindest Zugriff auf
Log-Auswertung haben,
das war Zabbix auch nicht so ohne weiteres,
das heißt, Zabbix ist ein bisschen,
finde ich, so ein bisschen aus der Zeit gefallen,
ja,
aber ich habe daheim immer noch einen Zabbix
am Start, weil ich den mal
eingerichtet habe und der läuft halt,
das ist auch noch ein bisschen ältere Version,
irgendwie 6.8 oder sowas,
was ist das, React Everywhere,
das ist der Office Installer,
ne,
ist das das Startmenü,
was bin ich da überhaupt sehend,
also ja,
das ist anscheinend das Startmenü,
also zumindest dieser Teil hier,
also ich wusste, dass bei Microsoft relativ viel
React ist,
ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es wusstet,
aber Office
im Browser ist auch React, ist auch eine
React-Anwendung,
es heißt ja auch nicht mehr Office, was
eines der bescheuertsten Renames
ever ist, warum eigentlich
wurde Microsoft, wurde
eigentlich Office 365, ich fand
übrigens Office 365 schon immer
bescheuert, ja, aber okay, warum
wurde eigentlich, wie kam man auf
die glorreiche Idee, Office 365
in Microsoft 365
umzubenennen, jeder
nennt das Ding Office,
warum Microsoft
365,
das ist so hängengeblieben,
einfach nur, ja, und
wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das
wusstet, die Browser-Version
von Office 365,
die ist auch React,
die ist auch in React programmiert,
ja,
wir haben auch tatsächlich auf der Arbeit noch
ein CheckMK, aber
der macht halt zum größten Teil so die klassischen
Monitoring-Sachen, so wie halt
läuft Zertifikat ab, ist das
Service da, antwortet der Agent
und sowas, so großartiges
Metriken-Collecten oder
gar Traces von
Anwendungen und sowas, und auch
die Log-Auswertung von CheckMK ist sehr
ja, hakelig, und ein
großes Problem, was CheckMK hat, was
Zabbix auch ein bisschen hat,
aber Zabbix nicht so
sehr, ein großes Problem von
CheckMK, was ich damit habe,
ist, dass die, glaube ich, dass, keine Ahnung,
wie alt CheckMK ist, ich sag jetzt einfach mal 15 Jahre
alt oder so, und dass die von
diesen 15 Jahren, 14
einhalb Jahre, keinen UI-Designer
hatten. Das CheckMK-UI
ist einfach, wir klatschen die Sachen
überall hin, wo wir gerade noch
einen Platz finden. Guckt euch dieses,
ja, das ist, das ist das schöne
Outboard-View, das, das wollen wir ja einfach gar
nicht, ja. Konfig.
Hier, ja.
Ja.
Ja, da wird's schon,
da wird's schon ekliger, man.
Ja, hier, diese,
diese, also das UI
von CheckMK ist wirklich, guckt euch
das hier an, Alter. Wer hat, wer, wer
macht sowas?
Ja, wer designt solche Oberflächen?
Und das sind jetzt nur kleine Ausschnitte, dass es übersichtlich
ist, aus denen ihren Docs,
normalerweise, wenn du sowas aufmachst,
dieser Abschnitt-Teil von einer,
ja, keine Ahnung,
ähm,
10-seitigen Konfig,
die du durchscrollen musst im Browser.
Ja, guckt euch, guckt euch diesen
Kram an. Also, die, die Typen bei
CheckMK, die hatten keinen UI-Designer, das ist übrigens
nix, was ich mir ausgedacht hab, dass die
keinen UI-Designer haben.
Das haben die, das haben die inoffiziell, inoffiziell
selbst bestätigt, weil die seit
einem halben Jahr oder so in ihrem
Word
oder wie man das nennt, haben die
nen UI-Designer, der dort regelmäßig postet.
Und der postet halt irgendwie erst seit einem halben Jahr.
Die hatten, die hatten die letzten Jahre einfach
keinen.
Ja gut, du kannst ja, wenn du weißt wie, ja.
Aber ist trotzdem wichtig, dass die Dinger irgendwie
bedienbar sind. Hab ich mich noch nicht mit beschäftigt.
Ja. Also das ist so
eins meiner Probleme, die ich mit CheckMK hab, dass
das Interface und die Konfig halt so für'n Arsch
ist. Plus, dass es halt
teilweise mega
unintuitiv
ist, wenn ich sowas hier lese,
im Dropdown-Menü haben wir zusätzlich noch
die Möglichkeit, Refresh all
Services tabula rasa auszuwählen.
Obviously, dass man das machen
kann. Ja, alles klar.
Ja, das hast du, das musst du manchmal machen,
wenn das irgendwelche neuen Services nicht discovert werden.
Also das Interface von CheckMK ist
wirklich grausam. Und nicht nur
die, nicht nur das Konfig-Interface ist
grausam. Ja, ich hab das sogar schon aufgemacht.
Nicht nur das Konfig-Interface ist grausam
von CheckMK, sondern auch
das reine, wir gucken uns jetzt die Sachen
an, Monitoring-Interface ist grausam.
Wenn ich mich jetzt dazwischen entscheiden
müsste, was ich
Interface-technisch
besser finde, als
CheckMK, also Zabbix oder
CheckMK, dann würde ich eindeutig sagen
Zabbix, aber es ist auch
nicht einfacher. Es ist zumindest etwas
logischer, wenn man sich dran gewöhnt
hat. Und man kann sich etwas einfacher dran gewöhnen.
Crap ist das
Zabbix-Interface auch.
Deswegen mag ich beides nicht so
wirklich.
Ja, deswegen gucken wir uns heute
Mittag mal
OpenObserve an. Das habe ich
letztens auf Hacker-News
gefunden. Und das
kann angeblich, natürlich das
allerwichtigste, Leute.
BlazinglyFast
while written in Rust.
Das
Kriterium schlechthin, warum wir
nur noch diese Software verwenden.
So, und die sagen,
die können alles in einem. Die
können,
ja, das kann man sich selbst installieren.
Die wollen ja einfach nur ihren Cloud-Shit verkaufen.
Die machen Logs,
Metriken, Dashboards,
Traces, alles
mögliche in einem Tool.
Plus, dass sie ganz normal
OpenTelemetry und Prometheus-Sachen
ingesten können.
Da bin ich mal gespannt,
ob das taugt.
Weil so Versprechungen von, ja, wir
sind die beste Monitoring-Lösung
überhaupt, gibt es ja einige.
Gehalten haben es wenige.
Was dafür spricht,
dass es gar nicht schlecht ist, sind die Github-Sternchen.
Und was ich nice finde,
dass es ein einziges, ein einzelnes Binary
ist zum Ausführen.
Das probieren wir heute Mittag mal aus.
Und wir probieren nicht den Service
von denen aus, sondern
wir installieren uns
das selbst.
Was in der Tat recht easy ist,
weil
man das einfach im Docker-Container starten kann.
Oder alternativ kann man sich, glaube ich, einfach auch das,
das ist übrigens kein Go-Binary,
das Rust-Binary runterladen und gut ist.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das taugt.
Gerade Integration von
OpenTelemetry mit Logs
und Prometheus ist nice,
weil sobald du Prometheus integrieren kannst,
schon von Bend gehört,
ja, da habe ich das Video gerade von Fireship aufgemacht,
sobald du Prometheus integrieren kannst,
kannst du gut wie alles.
Also da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Okay, dann lasst uns auch gerade mal
die aktuellen Shithub-Trends
uns angucken.
Hast du mal Bock auf einen 3D-Druck?
Champ in .NET,
um Chinesen-Cloud loszuwerden?
Was?
Okay.
Ich verstehe die Wörter,
aber ich verstehe nicht, was du
meinst.
Also ich verstehe, du meinst,
ob ich irgendwas programmieren kann,
um Chinesen-Cloud
loszuwerden.
Das verstehe ich nicht. Wieso?
Wie jetzt? Was jetzt?
Was soll der?
Tobo,
Nautilus, das musst du mir ein bisschen genauer erklären.
Ich meine,
ich kann schlecht was programmieren, was dir
in China was ausdruckt, oder?
Ach, jetzt weiß ich, was
du meinst. Hast du einen 3D-Drucker,
der Chinesen-Cloud
Sachen braucht,
dass er funktioniert, oder was?
Dann nimm doch Octoprint,
gibt es doch schon seit Jahren.
Das ist das Beste, was es gibt.
Ansonsten musst du mir das etwas genauer erklären.
Also hier, ich zeige euch das mal.
Octoprint
oder Octopie, da hat man es gleich
von Raspberry Pi.
Octoprint
Raspberry Pi drauf,
per USB an seinen 3D-Drucker angestöpselt
und man kann seinen 3D-Drucker
über das Webinterface
füttern, mit Druck aufdrehen, gucken, wie weit es ist
und alles. Und es gibt
tausende Plugins
für alles mögliche, was man so
haben können
möchte.
Sogar für Kameras, dass man
zugucken kann, wie gedruckt wird und so.
Wobei ich die Kamera wieder entfernt
habe. Also was ich noch habe, ich habe am
3D-Drucker vorne so eine
Beleuchtung dran,
dass es leuchtet, wenn er druckt,
was sehr nice ist, wenn man
eine Kamera in dem Raum hat
und gucken will, was das Gedrucke
gerade so macht.
Aber wenn man irgendwas braucht zum 3D-Drucker
steuern, ist Octoprint eigentlich das Beste.
Und dadurch, dass es das
Ja, so kannst du dir das dann zusammenbauen.
Und dadurch, dass es das als fertiges
Raspberry Pi Image gibt, mit Octoprint drinnen,
gibt es eigentlich kaum was einfacheres,
was man verwenden kann.
Die Anzeige hier, wie viel
Time left ist, ist nicht so hundertprozentig akkurat,
aber die ist
für grobe Richtwert ist die eigentlich ganz gut.
Zumal es Plugins gibt, um die genauer zu machen.
Also
plus minus paar Minuten genau ist die.
Was bei 3D-Druckjobs ja
reicht.
3D-Druckjobs sind ja selten unter
einer Stunde, wenn es ein bisschen
größeres ist.
Also Octoprint, das Beste.
Ich habe auch schon ewig nicht mehr updatet.
Ich habe noch irgendeine uralte Version drauf,
aber die geht halt einfach.
Und ich druck mit meinem 3D-Drucker auch gar nicht so viel.
Ich druck ab und zu mal entweder irgendwelche
Gehäuse für irgendwelches
Bastelkram.
Oder aber irgendwie Kleinkram.
Ich hab zum Beispiel letztens mal,
weil letztens ist auch schon wieder ein Jahr her,
mal ein Sieb gedruckt
für
eine Regenrinne,
die keine Standard-
Regenrinnengröße hat.
Für solche Sachen sind 3D-Drucker perfekt.
Man glaubt gar nicht mal, dieses
3D-Drucker Zeug, das
was ist so das 0815
Filament, was dabei ist, kann man das immer
nicht merken. Das ist sehr beständig.
Also das ist sehr stabil.
Was es glaube ich nicht so mag,
also mal gucken, wie lange das in der Regenrinne hält.
Was es glaube ich nicht so mag, ist Sonnenlicht
Einstrahlung, den ganzen Tag.
Wenn du heute ein Bambulab kaufst,
dann ist es Plug & Play, aber auch nur,
weil App wie der Chinesen von einmal an die...
Octoprint ist Python, das ist richtig.
Aber das ist doch für
Anwender egal so, was das ist.
Wenn schon, müsste das
rewritten in Rust sein. Moment, Moment.
Es gibt doch bestimmt Octoprint-Alternative
in Rust, oder?
Das kann ich mir...
Das...
Die Leute rewriten alles wie verrückt
in Rust. Okay, es gibt anscheinend
keine Octoprint-Alternative in Rust.
Es macht auch keinen Sinn, ehrlich gesagt.
Octoprint
ist ja wirklich nicht performance-kritisch, irgendwie.
Ja...
Nee, aber...
Das ist...
Erstens, ein Thema, was mich gerade
nicht sonderlich interessiert, weshalb
ich schon mal das nicht mache.
Das zweite ist, es ist ein enorm
Riesenprojekt, irgendwas in der Richtung zu bauen.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung davon.
Und es gibt eine gute Alternative, also
dann...
Dann sollte ich lieber den Fiat Champ
mal weiterbauen.
Der sicherlich immer noch keine Issues
hat, oder?
Nee, immer noch, obviously.
Immer noch nicht.
Also, was trennt ihr denn auf Shithub die Woche?
Zeigt mal her. Echt?
Okay.
Wusste ich gar nicht,
dass es sowas gibt.
Ich dachte, die ganzen 3D-Drucker haben alle eine USB-Schnittstelle,
wo du dann dein Raspberry Pi
anschließen kannst.
Zumindest alle, die ich bisher gesehen habe.
Ich habe mich da jetzt aber auch die letzten Jahre,
seitdem ich meinen habe, nicht mehr mit beschäftigt.
So ein typisches Thema wie
neuer PC kaufen. Ich beschäftige mich dann damit,
wenn es soweit ist.
Also, was trennt ihr diese Woche? Glance.
Dashboards. Ja, das braucht
TechnoTim.
Dass man
ja auch irgendwas in den drei Kubernetes-
Clustern daheim und einen
in der
Co-Location,
dass man da was hosten kann.
So, Chat, gebt mir den Desktop ab.
Written in Rust, ganz wichtig.
TimeSFM.
TimeSeriesFoundation. Ah, AI.
Ich weiß nicht, was das
sein soll.
MoreRelighting.
Ah, irgendwelches AI-Zeug.
Ok.
AI-Zeug.
AI-generated.
Content wird AI-generated
geleitet. Ok, alles klar.
Belichtet.
AI.
AI. China-Chinesen-Kram.
Warp Clash
API. What?
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was
das sein soll. Cloudflare
Warp Plus.
This project enables you to use Cloudflare
through subscription automation.
Was ist, was ist
Cloudflare Warp...
Ist das ein VPN?
Ist das ein...
Was? Das ist der DNS
von... Ok, es ist
so eine Art VPN.
Ach, deswegen...
Deswegen stehen da die Chinesen auch so drauf.
Ok. Die Uhr ist nice,
ne? Da weiß man jetzt
gar nicht mehr so genau, was Domain, Top-Level-Domain
und Sub-Domain ist. Ok, doch, man weiß es.
One ist die Top-Level-Domain.
One ist die eigentliche Domain und dann gibt es
eine Sub-Domain mit einer weiteren Sub-Domain.
Also, aber eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Idee.
Meinst du nicht, dass du eventuell
irgendwann von dem AI-Zeug abgehängt wirst,
wenn du dich damit so blockierend beschäftigst?
Beschäftige ich mich damit?
Blockierend? Ich gucke mir die ganzen Github-Projekte
dazu nicht an.
Weil es meistens für mich überhaupt nicht
klar ist, wofür die Dinger da sind
und ich mich weder für
Image-Generating noch sonst was interessiere.
Ich beschäftige mich da selektiv
damit, wenn ich es für sinnvoll
halte. Kennst du...
Ja, das ist die Facebook-
Geschichte, ja? Facebook-Image-Gedöns.
Lama, nicht das
Facebook-Image-Gedöns?
Außerdem, ich glaube, jeder wird
von der AI-Entwicklung abgehängt,
der sich nicht jeden Tag vier Stunden damit beschäftigt,
was Neues gibt.
So...
Ja, und ich meine, was juckt
einen
irgendein weiteres Chat-GPT-Desktop-
Web-Interface? Who cares?
Auch AI-Image-Generating...
Ja, guck, das ist gefühlt
wieder 80% irgendwelches
Image-Generating-AI diese Woche gewesen.
No offense, doch.
Ich bin voll offended, ich ban dich jetzt.
Direkt Kick
für immer.
Ich bin immer wieder...
Ich entdecke immer wieder neue
GitHub-Sachen. Mir ist erst letztens
aufgefallen, dass jetzt hier auch neuerdings
Developers trenden können.
Developers, Developers,
Developers.
Ah, siehste?
Aber ist Lama nicht...
Lama ist doch die Facebook-AI.
Warum heißt das dann OL-Lama?
Mein Gott, können die ihre Produkte nicht
mal gescheit benennen?
Okay, das sind wohl die trendenden Developer
diese Woche.
Alles zu hier.
Und eine Runde AskIquarium.
Ja, Chat, jetzt wo ein bisschen mehr Leute
da sind, kennt ihr irgendeine
gute Seite? McFly, danke schön für den Sub.
Kennt ihr irgendeine gute Seite,
die
wöchentliche IT-News-
Übersichten bietet, die was taugt?
Ja. Ich hab bisher
noch keine gefunden, die mir gefällt.
Heise macht sowas nicht mehr, die hatten früher mal
ganz brauchbare.
Es gab früher...
Es gibt keine
Hacker-News, gescheite Hacker-News
Wochenzusammenfassung mehr.
Ich, ich, ich sag,
Hacker-News ist so ein Ding,
das musst du jeden Tag lesen. Ich meine
Wochenzusammenfassung. Es gab früher eine ganz gute
Hacker-News-Zusammenfassung, die gibt es
aber schon eine Weile nicht mehr.
Hacker-News guck ich auch öfters rein, aber ich meine
Wochenzusammenfassung.
Irgendwas wurde so, so,
sagen wir mal, Freitag, Samstag oder Samstag,
mal gucken kannst du, ey, was ist in die
Woche wirklich wichtiges IT-mäßig
passiert? Habe ich vielleicht irgendwas
verpasst? An die wichtigsten
Sachen kriegt man ja immer mit.
Sei es hier im Stream,
über Twitter, was ja schon seit Ewigkeiten
nicht mehr Twitter heißt, aber sagt, gibt
es, Chat, gibt es von euch irgendjemand,
der X sagt, anstelle von Twitter?
Also, ich sag immer
Twitter und ich werd auch weiterhin Twitter sagen.
Selbst, selbst wenn die
Domain mittlerweile ja auch komplett unbenannt
ist, ne, also...
Einer sagt
X. X ist auch
so eine dumme Domain, Alter.
X, könnte man sagen, ja.
Ja, das, das
sagen die immer in irgendwelchen
News-Sendungen.
X, ehemalig, wird ehemals Twitter.
Ich glaube sogar, dass
PayPal ursprünglich mal X
hieß, gell, und
dass dann PayPal wurde...
Ich hab mir
irgendwann mal die History davon
angeschaut, ich weiß nicht mehr genau.
Zumindest, irgendwie,
irgendwie finde das geil, dass
die Dinger X heißen.
Ampel, danke.
Pog-Subscription.
Das erste Logo hat ein X drauf, okay.
Wie gesagt, ich sag auch, ich sag auch
immer Twitter und ich werde auch
weiterhin Twitter, weil
das Ding ist halt,
bei Twitter hast du
nicht gesagt, ich poste jetzt was
auf Twitter, da haben die Leute gesagt, ein Tweet
oder getweetet oder so.
Das fand ich eigentlich immer ein ganz nettes Wort,
das von
allen immer, also jedem klar war,
man postet was auf Twitter, AI-Goals.
Du wirst nicht
abgehängt von AI-Entwicklung bei dem Namen.
Wie gerade der Chat
befürchtet hat, ja.
Aber wie nennt man das denn auf
X? Ja, ge-XT,
ge-XT, ich hab was ge-XT,
das, ge-XT heißt bei uns
auf Deutsch eher wie sowas, ich hab's auf
einen Schlag ausgedrungen.
Ich hab was ge-XT.
Das ist aber ziemlich Boomer.
Gesichtsbuch, anstatt Facebook
zu sagen.
Sagst du auch,
ähm,
sagst du auch Win-Doof von
Mini-Weich?
Das ist auch so ein typisches Boomer-Ding.
Mit dem Under-Serial.
Aber ausgerechnet mit dem
Under-Serial, wie kommst du da drauf?
Der macht doch jetzt, der macht doch jetzt, ähm,
China-Chinesen
Review-Kram.
Nicht Mikro-Weich.
Mini-Mini-Weich.
Also, sobald
einer Win-Doof sagt,
ist das für mich so der, der
Mega-Boomer-Indicator.
Da weißt du Bescheid.
Und, und,
wisst ihr, die gleichen Leute,
die gleichen Leute, die sagen auch nicht
Mehrwertsteuer, sondern Märchensteuer.
Da hat mich der Chat
draufgebracht, aber das ist wirklich so.
Kennt, kennt ihr so Leute?
Das sind, das ist wirklich so.
Das ist ein heftiger Boomer-Indicator.
Ja?
Die ist mir auch letztens schon
aufgefallen, ja.
Die ist mir auch letztens schon aufgefallen.
Die Partei für Schulmed, für
für Dings, Schulmedizinische Verjüngungsforschung.
Die ist mir auch letztens aufgefallen.
Wobei, mein Wahl-O-Mat-Ergebnis
war ja eh etwas weird.
Ich sollte irgendwelche,
5G-Skeptiker
wählen, wisst ihr doch.
Ich sollte die übelsten
Keck-Alo-Leute wählen.
Wobei der Wahl-O-Mat ja nicht sagt, was man
wählen soll, sondern nur,
womit man insgesamt prozentual
die meisten Übereinstimmungen
hatte. Und vielleicht habe
ich einfach zu, ja,
weird abgestimmt,
zu weit auseinanderliegend,
dass nur solche merkwürdigen Parteien
das hatten.
Also, also, das Ergebnis von meinem Wahl-O-Mat
war, der höchste
hatte tatsächlich nur 77%.
Und das waren irgendwelche
Keck-Alo-5G-Skeptiker.
Ich habe schon wieder
vergessen, wie die hießen.
Die wurden,
witzigerweise, die wurden auch während
Corona-Zeit, während der Corona-Zeit
gegründet. Und da sind wahrscheinlich auch
irgendwelche, die Bill Gates nicht mögen,
wegen Mikrochips und so.
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie die heißen, die ich wählen soll.
Auch dem Wahl-O-Mat. Aber die
sind, die stehen skeptisch 5G
gegenüber.
Mehrwertsteuer.
Das sagen die ganzen Boomer.
Also, nicht die, viele Boomer sagen
anstatt Mehrwertsteuer, Märchensteuer.
Ja.
Wie gesagt, die gleichen Leute sagen auch winddoof.
Weißt du, was das, weißt du,
was das Schlimme daran ist?
Das Problem hat dein Vater,
aber das gleiche Problem könnte heute auch
ein Zwölfjähriger haben.
Da habe ich auch teilweise den Eindruck,
also, das muss ich anders sagen.
Noch,
also, als ich mal,
ich mache jetzt den,
ich mache jetzt den krassesten Boomer-Antwort
ever für euch. Als ich mal
in eurem Alter war, ja.
Also, als
ich mal so, keine Ahnung, 13,
14, 15 war.
Ihr seid älter, ich weiß.
Als ich mal, als ich mal
so 14 rum war, da habe ich mir
Gedanken gemacht, okay, wie wird denn das
eigentlich in Zukunft sein? Und da war
ich mir sehr sicher, wirklich,
du hättest mich von nichts anderem überzeugen, aber ich war
sehr sicher, dass jede weitere
Generation, die nach mir
kommt, noch mehr Plan
von Technik und Computerkram
und Internet und allem hat, als
ich, weil die ja ganz intuitiv
damit aufwachsen.
Dass das für die einfach das Selbstverständlichste
auf der Welt sein wird,
ja, ihren Computer zu bedienen,
Internetmäßig sich zu bewegen
und neue Sachen,
ähm,
neue Sachen zu lernen, aufzunehmen.
Da habe ich mich aber extrem
getäuscht. Wenn ich mir das
angucke, 12-Jährige
heute haben gefühlt
genauso wenig Plan,
wie die, keine Ahnung, 60
plus-Jährigen. Die
haben anderweitig,
also, man kann
nicht sagen, dass exakt das gleiche ist,
ja, ähm,
bei den 60 plus-Jährigen hast du dann sowas
wie, oh, warum muss man das so kompliziert
machen, man kann doch einfach auch einen Fax schicken oder,
oh, ich mag das nicht,
dass der Fernseher jetzt so eine komische App
hat dafür und so.
Das hast du eher bei 60, oder zum Beispiel
so, ah, wo ist denn jetzt hier der
Restart-Knopf und sowas
in der Richtung, ja, wie starte ich
das jetzt neu? Früher konntest du den Fernseher
einfach ein- und ausschalten, heute muss ich eine App
closen und wieder starten und so. Das ist so
eher der 60-Jährige-Boomer-Take.
Die haben
damit Probleme, ja.
Ähm,
ja, aber die jungen Leute haben mit sowas hier dann
teilweise Probleme.
Wo du denkst, ey,
wo ist das Problem?
Dann geh an deinen Desktop, installiere das
und benutze das.
Aber das hat doch keinen App-Store.
Wie soll das
gehen ohne App-Store?
Geh einfach auf die Webseite, klick das an
und so. Ja, aber,
wie mache ich das denn?
Die sind anderweitig lost.
Gerade auch bei
Internet- und PC-Problemen heutzutage,
ja.
Letztens hat mich tatsächlich,
da war ich echt komplett verwirrt,
ich bin,
ich bin langgelaufen bei uns,
zum,
ich glaube zum Rewe, ja,
bin ich langgelaufen
und da läuft man an so einer, an so
einem, an so ein paar Wohnsiedlungen vorbei
und irgendwo da in der Ecke ist auch
eine Schule und dann
fragt mich irgendein, keine Ahnung,
10-Jähriger, 12-Jähriger, ah,
wissen sie, wo es hier zur,
ja, XYZ-Schule geht?
Und da gucke ich
ihn an, denke mir so,
ja, irgendwo da vorne,
ähm, hast,
hast du nicht Google Maps auf dem Handy?
Ach so, ja, habe ich.
Da dachte ich auch,
hä?
Man hat ein Handy auf dem Kopf, Google Maps?
Hä?
Also da denke ich mir teilweise, die Leute sind,
heute so, mit so ultra-banalen
Dinger, teilweise Losts, ja?
Und, und bei den
60-plus-jährigen Boomern wäre das Problem
anders gewesen. Die hätten vielleicht
noch gecheckt,
dass sie ja ein Handy haben, aber sie hätten
nicht gewusst, wie sie es bedienen müssen.
Aber auch so ein Ding, so ein typisches Beispiel,
wo ich mir, wo ich mir
früher gedacht habe, das ist heute ganz
selbstverständlich,
ja, sind Leute heute
die, sagen wir mal,
Online-Spiele spielen. Ja, was, was ist denn
gerade der neueste Hype bei jungen Leuten?
Fortnite ist es ja auf jeden Fall nicht mehr.
Was ist denn gerade so das, das, das,
ähm, was kommt denn eigentlich nach?
Zuma. Das, äh,
was ist denn so gerade so das, das Zuma-Game?
Fortnite nicht mehr. Valorant?
Näh.
Valorant, Valorant glaube ich nicht.
Valorant ist eher was für die
Gamer-Grills.
TikTok,
Clash of, ja, irgendwelches dumme Mobile-
Ja, aber sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal
Valorant, ja, oder sagen wir mal Valorant,
oder, oder, oder Fortnite, ist vollkommen egal.
Vielleicht spielen ja manche auch
zuerst Minecraft, Minecraft immer noch,
ja, das stimmt. Zumindest
eine Sache, wo ich früher
fest davon überzeugt war, ist,
dass die Leute, die heute in dem Alter
sind, ja, die Fortnite spielen
und so, die dann sich Frankfurt
am Südbahnhof vor die Straßenbahn
stellen, um den Loser-Dance zu machen
und so, das war eines der größten Grinch-Momente
ever, die ich je gesehen hab.
Zumindest, ich hab damals
gedacht, für die ist vollkommen
klar, wenn es
beispielsweise ruckelt und laggt,
was der Unterschied ist.
Ist es nicht. Die Leute checken
es heute noch nicht. Weil ich dachte mir,
ey, das ist einfach
vollkommen selbstverständlich
und logisch für jemanden, der
2024, äh,
Computerspiele spielt,
dass der den Unterschied instinktiv
kapiert zwischen
lag und ruckelt zum Beispiel, ja.
Oder auch diese Geschichte mit, ey,
das muss irgendwie an mir liegen, dass es
laggt und sowas in der Richtung.
Nee, zum größten Teil liegt das irgendwo auf der
Strecke dazwischen am Server, ansonsten was.
Die dann irgendwelche komischen
Tutorials machen auf
ähm
die sich dann irgendwelche komischen Tutorials
auf YouTube angucken
um Ping-Loss festzustellen.
Leute, ich hab ne, ich hab,
das ist jetzt kein Witz, ja, es gibt Tutorials
auf YouTube,
die beschreiben, wie man Ping-Loss
feststellt. Passt mal auf, und zwar
so.
TracerouteAliExpress.com
Oh nein!
Ping, äh, Packet-Loss!
Oh nein, Leute! Ganz schrecklich!
Packet-Loss!
Und dann flappen sie aus.
IP-Leak, MonkaS.
Da drehen sie, da drehen sie durch, ja.
Es gibt, das ist jetzt kein
Witz, es gibt Tutorials.
Die, die zeigen dir sowas.
Zum Packet-Loss feststellen.
Das ist absolut komplett Banane.
Das hat
absolut nichts mit Packet-Loss zu tun.
Null! Null Komma gar nichts
hat das mit Packet-Loss zu tun.
Ja, wir können das auch,
weiß jemand die Option für
kontinuierliches Traceroute?
Gibt's doch auch so ein Tool für,
oder kann das Traceroute sogar selbst?
Ich mach das zu selben.
Ja, es gibt so ein kontinuierliches
Traceroute mit Terminal UI.
Und das zeigt dir dann das halt an.
Oder, äh, genau das
meine ich. Ja, ja, MTR glaube ich.
Ja.
Ja. Ja, ja.
MTR.
Es könnte auch
Traceroute-T sein, ich weiß nicht.
Ne, das ist,
ne, das ist, das ist, ne, Moment.
TOS. MonkaTOS.
Ne, das ist
irgendwas anderes.
MTR, wie geht das jetzt? AliExpress.com
Ja.
Fuck, Leute! Packet-Loss!
OMG!
Mein Internet ist kaputt!
91% Packet-Loss!
Und dann
rasten sie aus und denken sich, fuck,
mein Internet ist immer...
Früher war ich mir sicher, dass Leute,
die das 2024 sich angucken,
wissen, dass ihr Internet nicht
kaputt ist und sie keinen Packet-Loss haben.
Zumindest, Leute, überlegt euch jetzt mal,
seriously, überlegt euch mal ernsthaft.
Ihr hättet einen Packet-Loss
von 97%
beim dritten Hop.
Ihr könntet euer Internet nicht benutzen,
es würde einfach nicht funktionieren.
Es würde nicht einfach mal irgendwelche Schüsse in
Fortnite nicht registrieren oder sowas.
Es wäre komplett unbenutzbar.
Und die Frage, die man sich jetzt ja auch stellen
muss, ist, wenn ich beim dritten
Hop schon 98% Packet-Loss
habe, wie kann es dann sein, dass
ich beim sechzehnten Hop 0%
habe? Komisch, oder?
Dann würdet ihr eigentlich erwarten, jeder weitere
Punkt müsste dann mindestens genauso viel haben.
Ja.
Und das hätte ich eigentlich
erwartet, dass Leute,
2024 junge Leute,
dass ohne Probleme,
instinktiv, weil sie
damit aufgewachsen sind, solche
Zusammenhänge verstehen.
Aber es ist nicht so. Ja, und, ja,
und dann schnappen die Leute
irgendwelche Dinge auf, von
Packet-Loss
bis Buffer-Bloat oder
whatever und werfen damit um
sich in einen Kontext, der überhaupt
nichts damit zu tun hat.
Ja, genauso, wenn sie anfangen, dann
der Meinung sind, oh ja, hier, ich brauche
irgendwie
einen Router mit Gaming-
Funktionen, der ein bisschen QoS macht,
aber im Prinzip
ist ihre Internetverbindung halt zu
0,005% aufgewachsen.
Aber ich brauche unbedingt
QoS. Da hätte ich auch
erwartet früher, dass die Leute heute instinktiv
verstehen, dass das nur sinnvoll ist,
wenn die Verbindung einen gewissen
Auslastungsgrad hat.
Wo nichts ist, musst du keine
Warteschlangen haben, die du dann mit QoS
priorisierst, wenn einfach nichts
sich aufstaut.
Ja. Und das sind so
Dinger, wo ich halt echt früher gedacht hätte, ey, das
checkt jeder, jeder, der 2024
quasi in meinem damaligen Alter
ist. Aber nee.
Das ist so ein Peak
gab das. Meine
Generation und die Generation danach,
da gab es so einen Peak in
ja, wie soll man sagen,
Endnisstand,
was so Computer, Internet,
IT-Technik angeht.
Und dann ging es wieder runter.
Ja. Die Generation,
meine Generation, die ist
genau so gespalten.
Es gibt einmal die Leute,
die in meinem, ich meine, ich werde 40 dieses
Jahr, ja, die in meinem Alter
die übelsten Boomer schon sind,
die zum Stammtisch gehen
und da rumflamen
und gerne faxen
und sich darüber beschweren, dass man jetzt
mit einer Krankenkassen-App
sein Zeug angucken kann und sowas.
Und dann gibt es die Leute,
also, das liegt halt
daran, wo die in ihrer Jugend abgebogen
sind, ja. Als ich so 14, 5,
12, 13, 14,
15 war, da konnte man halt
in meine Generation konnte in zwei Richtungen
abbiegen, ja. In die klassische
Boomer-Richtung, so oldschool, so
wir schicken weiter
Faxe und finden alles
neue Kacke. Oder in die Richtung,
in die ich abgebogen bin, man
interessiert sich für Computerkram
und Internet und Technik.
Das heißt, in meiner Generation
gibt es Leute, die sind so
krasse Boomer wie 60, 70 plus
oder es gibt Leute wie
mich, die jetzt vielleicht auch nicht mehr
ganz mithalten können bei den neuesten
Boomer-Trends. Vieles kann ich nicht
nachvollziehen, warum man es geil findet,
aber ich kann zumindest Twitch-Emotes,
was richtige Boomer nicht
können. Und die
Generation danach, die war noch ein
bisschen besser, was Technik angeht,
aber ich glaube, das liegt daran,
weil du dich in meiner Generation,
also, sagen wir mal so,
die Generation vor mir,
die hat es ja noch, also die paar,
die sich dort für Technik interessiert haben,
die mussten ja wirklich richtig Low-Level
steigen.
Die mussten Assembler programmieren
oder
irgendwelche Dinger zusammenlöten oder
whatever. Ja, aber bei meiner
Generation wurde das langsam aber sicher
Mainstream und die Generation danach
noch ein bisschen mehr, aber ich glaube,
man musste sich, es war noch nicht so
simpel, dass man sich gar nicht
mehr mit beschäftigen muss. Heute ist
das komplett easy, so die 0815
Sachen zu machen, die eigentlich
komplex sind. Ihr müsst euch mal überlegen,
was du mit, also, wenn du, wenn du
ein Smartphone, ich hol mal hier,
wenn du ein Smartphone hast, ja, also nicht nur,
was da allein schon an Technik drinnen steckt,
wenn man so eine App öffnet wie YouTube,
was da an riesen Sachen dahinter
eigentlich alles funktionieren muss,
damit du dir in der YouTube App überhaupt
das angucken kannst, so. Und das
funktioniert heute einfach
so gut und,
ja, sagen wir mal, so intuitiv,
dass du außer App installieren auf dem
Smartphone da nicht relativ, nicht mal viel
für machen musst, ja. Du musst dir keine Gedanken
drüber machen, um die Sachen, die du da machen musst,
um die Sachen drum herum. Und ich glaube,
deswegen können die Leute halt sich super,
was so Mediensachen angeht,
bewegen, aber sobald was nicht
geht, sind glaube ich viele
Zoomer heute auch sehr lost bei
technischen Problemen.
Zwar auf andere Art, wie die, wie die Generation
vor mir, aber auch,
ähm,
auch so ein Ding,
manchmal
höre ich tatsächlich noch Radio,
ja, und da sagen die
dann sowas durch wie,
bla bla bla, Radio
105.8
oder, wenn das
irgendein, irgendein Zoomer hört
heutzutage, meint ihr, die
wissen noch, was mit 105.8
überhaupt gemeint ist?
Frequenzen einstellen an einem Radio?
Was,
was soll das überhaupt sein? Du machst die
App auf, auf deinem Handy von dem Radio
und es geht halt.
Du musst nicht an einem Radio eine Frequenz einstellen.
Ah, das juckt.
Was ist ein Zoomer?
Alles, was jünger ist als
ich.
So genaue
Definitionen gibt es ja nicht.
Genauso wie es keine genaue Definition
für Boomer gibt. Man muss sagen,
klar, viele sagen, ja,
das ist diese, ist die Baby-Boomer-Generation,
aber ist ja gar nicht so wirklich, ja.
Mit Boomer ist eigentlich alles
gemeint, was so
das typische Boomer-Verhalten
aufweist.
So, ich mag Technik
nicht, ich fick lieber Faxe,
ich will nicht, dass mein Fernseher
eine App hat,
ich geh zum Stammtisch
und kotz mich über Windräder aus
und solche Dinger. Ja, das ist so
die ersten Sachen, die mir so einfallen.
Genau. Boomer ist
keine Generation, sondern irgendwie so
eine Lebenseinstellung. Genau, genau.
Genauso wie ich letztens auf
Twitter gelernt hab, dass
Weißsein auch keine Hautfarbe
ist, sondern eine Einstellung.
Da hab ich mir auch gedacht, okay, genug Twitter für heute,
sorry, sorry, genug Ex, genug
Ex.com für heute, ich mach wieder aus.
Ja, und weil die halt
glaub ich auch zum größten Teil am
Smartphone hängen. Was nicht schlimm
ist, ich mein, jeder, was er
fürs tägliche Leben braucht, ja.
Wie nennt sich eigentlich dann die Generation
nach Z? Fängt das dann wieder bei A an?
Ruckel und Lag ist ein
Unterschied, ja. Ruckeln
ist bei dir performancebedingt auf
dem Rechner. Ich mein, ja,
bevor jetzt die Leute wieder ankommen, actually Max, das
kann auch das eine durch das andere. Ja, es gibt
auch Spiele, die ruckeln dadurch, dass das Server nicht
schnell genug hinterherkommt. Aber
das ist meistens ein deutlich anderes
Ruckeln als performancebasiertes
Ruckeln, ja. Also wenn jetzt irgendwie
50.000 Gegner bei dir auf dem Bildschirm angezeigt
werden müssen und deine CPU,
GPU und so weiter hinterherkommt, dann hast du
performancebedingtes
Ruckeln bei dir auf dem Rechner, ja. Wenn du
da mit 5 FPS rumruckelst.
Also hat nichts damit
zu tun, ob beispielsweise das Server
nicht mehr hinterherkommt, die ganzen Daten
zu prozessen, Netzwerkprobleme
dazwischen sind. Es gibt einmal, sagen wir mal,
das Server- schrägstrich-netzwerkbasierte.
Das ist das, was man eigentlich normalerweise unter
lag versteht. Und es gibt
ruckeln. Ruckeln ist für mich eigentlich
Client-basierte Performanceprobleme und
lag ist für mich Netzwerk- schrägstrich-Serverprobleme.
Und das kannst du eigentlich in der Regel
auch ganz gut unterscheiden, wenn du nicht
alles automatisch als lag abstempelst.
Übrigens, wusstet ihr, dass
Vodafone jetzt Super
WLAN hat?
Ja, richtig
Ach ja, und wisst ihr,
was Super WLAN ist?
Nein, nein, nein, es ist nicht
WiFi 7 oder so. Es ist
im Prinzip das, zumindest
zum Teil,
es ist im Prinzip das, was
jeder halbwegs
brauchbare, auch
nicht Smart Home, es ist das, was
jeder halbwegs brauchbare
Access Point macht.
Nämlich zu gucken, welche
WLAN-Frequenzen, welche Kanäle
sind hier in der Umgebung
nicht so viel benutzt
und dann schaltet es diesen
Kanal um.
Es ist im Prinzip ein automatisches
WLAN-Kanal auswählen
aufgrund der Umgebung.
Also das, was seit Jahren,
wenn nicht seit Jahrzehnten, die etwas
besseren Access Points, also es gibt bestimmt schon
über 10 Jahre Access Points, die das machen.
Das ist überhaupt gar
nichts besonderes. Ja, Unify macht
das ewig schon. Das machen sehr viele ewig schon.
Automatische Kanalauswahl.
Und
dementsprechend
ist das eigentlich gar nichts
tolles und man fragt sich eher,
warum macht das das Vodafone Ding
nicht standardmäßig
ohne Super WLAN?
Das kann doch jede Fritz...
Ich sag doch, das kann,
ob sie Fritzbox kann, kann ich persönlich
nicht bestätigen. Ich verwende das WLAN auf
meiner Fritzbox nicht, aber ich würde mich wundern,
wenn sie es nicht könnte.
Das kann jeder
etwas
oder sagen wir mal,
das kann jeder nicht super
billig Access Point.
Also, wenn du jetzt auf Amazon gehst und
dir für 8 Euro
den billigsten, der billigsten TP-Link
Access Points... Gucken wir doch mal.
Gucken wir mal nach.
TP-Link Access Point.
Was ist der billigste TP-Link Access Point,
den wir kriegen? Hier, beste.
So, 18 Euro.
So, wie kriegen wir jetzt raus,
ob der das kann?
Oh fuck.
Das ist ja, das ist ja antik, man.
802.11b.
Wann war denn das?
Wann war denn das? 1998
oder was? Ah, ne.
1999.
WLAN Standard von
1999, okay. Aber
das ergibt keinen Sinn. Warum soll der dann 300
Mbit pro Sekunde
schaffen?
Ich...
Ich glaube, das Ding ist
einfach... Das stimmt einfach
nicht, was da steht. Ich glaube, das stimmt einfach nicht,
was da steht.
Aber, kann man sogar
per PoE? Ach, guck mal,
der kann doch N. Ja, das hätte mich jetzt
auch gewundert, wenn nicht. Okay, wir gucken
jetzt mal rein, ob der
das kann. Ja?
PDF...
Ah, boah!
Die Webseite, man.
Gucken... Nach was soll ich ihn suchen, ob der das kann?
Automatische
Channel, ähm...
Auswahl...
Die suchen nach Channel.
Gibt's net.
Channel?
Was ist denn das denn schon wieder für
ein Schrott?
WLAN Settings...
Ja, Channel. Auto!
Auto!
Der kann das, Leute!
Ein...
Auto.
Ein 18-Euro-Accesspoint
von TP-Link auf Amazon kann das.
Also, wir reden hier nicht von einem
Premium-Feature, was Vodafone
hier anbietet.
Aber Super-WLAN.
Das verwirrt übrigens auch ganz viele Leute.
Ja, das hab ich auf Twitter schon gesehen.
Die lassen sich dann vom Support erzählen,
ah, WLAN-Probleme, sie brauchen Super-WLAN
und whatever.
Okay, Moment. Ich muss mir mal den
Werbefilm von Vodafone jetzt angucken.
Du hast zu Hause Probleme
mit deinem WLAN?
Dann kauf dir einen ordentlichen
WLAN-Accesspoint. Oder zwei.
Ja, in so einem Haus ist es durchaus
auch mal sinnvoll, zwei zu platzieren.
Gerade, wenn man den Keller noch mit abdecken will.
...Distanzen, dicke Wände oder
viele verbundene Geräte können die
WLAN-Leistung einschränken.
Die Lösung? Das neue
Vodafone Super-WLAN.
Das Super-WLAN wird an dicken
Wänden halt auch überhaupt gar nichts ändern.
Null. Wenn du richtig
fette Betonwände hast,
welchen WLAN-Channel du da jetzt ausfüllst,
...ich mein, man muss sagen,
2,4 Gigahertz geht eh schon besser durch Wände
als 5 Gigahertz.
Mit der intelligenten Empfangstechnologie
für deinen Router sicherst du dir eine super
smarte, super zuverlässige
WLAN-Verbindung für all deine Geräte.
Das Software-Update
ist in deinem Giga-Zuhause-Tarif
inklusive und kann jetzt kostenlos
aktiviert werden.
Erzähl ihr auch noch, was das macht?
Du brauchst noch mehr Reichweite?
Dann hol dir bis zu fünf...
Den Super-WLAN-Verstärker!
...fünf passende
Super-WLAN-Verstärker mit dem neuesten
WiFi-6-Standard dazu.
Für nur 2,99 Euro im Monat.
Sie sorgen für optimalen
WLAN-Empfang überall bei dir zu Hause.
Ja gut.
Super-WLAN-basiert...
Das ist schon
nett verkehrt.
Wenn man wirklich das...
Wenn man will, dass es einfach nur im letzten Winkel
noch irgendwie geht, kann man da schon einen Repeater hinstellen.
Warum nicht? Am besten sind natürlich zwei
Access-Points.
Jeweils mit der gleichen SSID und...
Die müssen schon angeschlossen sein.
Ein Netzwerkkabel.
Am besten sich untereinander austauschen.
Dass dann auch das Handoff von einem Gerät
zu anderen funktioniert.
...moderner Mesh-Technologie und erzeugt
zusammen mit den Super-WLAN-Verstärkern
ein einheitliches...
Wie genau
soll ein einzelner
Access-Point Mesh-Technologie
machen?
Eine Frage, wie das funktionieren soll.
... das WLAN-Netzwerk in deinem Zuhause.
So kannst du nahtlos
und störungsfrei mit deinen Geräten
im Internet surfen.
Super-WLAN ist darauf programmiert,
dein Heimnetz zu optimieren.
Es prüft kontinuierlich deine WLAN-Verbindungen
und verbessert sie automatisch.
So sind stabilere Übertragungen
möglich.
Mit der neuen Super-Connect-App
hast du noch mehr Kontrolle über dein Super-WLAN
und kannst deine Vodafone-Station
und deine Easybox 805 ganz einfach
einrichten.
Die App zeigt dir auch die beste Position
für deinen Verstärker.
Und du kannst damit dein WLAN bequem ein- oder ausschalten.
Das ist ja gar nicht mal
so verkehrt,
wenn das auch funktioniert.
Und die WLAN-Zugangsdaten
im Handumdrehen ändern.
Wie kommuniziert denn die App mit dem Router
dann bzw. mit dem Access-Point?
Über Bluetooth oder wie?
Egal, ob du schon Vodafone-Kundin
bist oder es werden willst.
Hol dir jetzt
kostenlos zu deinem Kabel
oder DSL-Tarif und in wenigen Schritten
Super-WLAN.
WLAN.
Auf vodafone.de slash super-wlan
oder einfach im Vodafone-Shop
bei dir um die Ecke.
Okay, alles klar.
Also das, was der Chat
gerade meinte,
das war...
Ich muss mal kurz runter scrollen.
Ja, das können eh nicht viele
nach Problemen ordentlich googeln.
Ja, das ist auch so ein Punkt,
dass es genug Zoomer gibt, die denken,
Snapchat-Bilder sind wirklich
weg, nachdem sie gelöscht wurden.
Keine Möglichkeit, das ist irgendwie anders.
Gleich was zu sagen.
Ich wollte eigentlich noch hier was zu sagen.
Ja, das macht Vodafone schon clever.
Viele Boomer kaufen jetzt
bestimmt neue Geräte wegen dem Super-WLAN.
Das Ding ist, was ich die ganze Zeit
eigentlich sagen wollte damit auch,
nicht nur die Boomer,
die jungen Leute heute auch.
Die klassischen zwei Generationen,
die checken, dass das eigentlich gar nichts
besonderes ist.
Und die 1.3 ist meine Generation,
die danach und teilweise ein bisschen die
und noch danach und vielleicht ein paar
teilweise von die davor.
Die Großteil der Zoomer haben überhaupt keinen Plan.
Welchen Router kannst du empfehlen?
Fritzbox geht bei mir kaputt.
Oder haben Hardware-Bugs,
die dann bei Sput...
Echt? Also, die Dinger funktionieren
auch in der Regel recht zuverlässig.
Da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht bei dir.
Der hat Sender durchgebrannt.
Okay.
Ehrlich gesagt,
ich finde die Fritzbox als
Kombi-Gerät gar nicht schlecht.
Ich habe auch eine, weil ich benutze die auch für VoIP.
Und VoIP möchte man ja eigentlich nicht selber machen.
Also SIP und
irgendwelche anderen Connection-Dinger.
Ich habe auch eine Fritzbox und die habe ich
seit Jahren schon. Die geht.
Wobei ich halt bei meiner Fritzbox
das WLAN nicht verwende dran.
Vielleicht wäre das für dich auch sinnvoll.
Du machst alles mit der Fritzbox, wofür die gut funktioniert.
Und alles andere nicht.
Also mein WLAN geht über
zwei extra Access-Points.
Mit der Fritzbox
mache ich im Endeffekt VoIP.
Und ja, meine
Fritz-Thermostate für die Heizung
sind noch dran angeschlossen.
Ich glaube, das war es zum Großen und Ganzen,
was das Ding macht. Ich habe auch nur eine billige Fritzbox.
So eine ganz...
Die hat sogar nur 100 Mbit-Anschlüsse.
So alt ist sie schon.
Mir ist
kein anderer Kombi-Ruhe
guter bekannt, der alles das kann,
was die Fritzbox kann.
Und gleichermaßen
auch so zuverlässig und gut funktioniert.
Was es bei dir ja nicht macht.
Und gut zu bedienen ist.
Die Dinger sind schon nicht schlecht.
Ich habe da früher auch gerne drüber gelästert.
Aber als Kombi-Gerät
für Leute,
die sich nicht so sehr damit beschäftigen wollen,
ist das eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Nix, solange ich mich nicht
drum kümmern muss.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich weiß, dass es mit der Generation zu tun hat.
Ich meine, guck mal, die Leute vor mir,
die Generation vor mir,
da gab es noch keine Computer daheim.
Wie sollten die sich groß damit beschäftigen?
Und dementsprechend, wie sollten die feststellen,
dass sie sich dafür interessieren?
Heute sieht es doch ganz anders aus.
Heute hat jeder ein Computer daheim,
jeder Smartphones, Tablets.
Also heute ist die Berührung mit der Technik doch deutlich größer
als früher.
Keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du dagegen klagen,
aber keine Chance.
Können kann man viel.
Im Zweifelsfall steht das bestimmt auch in den Nutzerbedingungen drin,
dass die Nachrichten auf unbestimmte Zeit
gespeichert werden dürfen.
Wahrscheinlich trittst du auch jegliche Rechte
am Inhalt der Nachrichten an Whatsapp ab oder sowas.
Ja, gibt's auch.
Ja, das sind dann aber nicht die typischen
Fortnite-Spieler.
So, mal gucken, ob es mittlerweile wieder Package-Updates
gibt, weil wir haben ja schon eine halbe Stunde
keine Package-Updates mehr gemacht.
Nee, okay, gut.
Adios Vox, danke für den Sub.
Porke Subscriptions
heute hier.
Schlag auf Schlag.
Excellent. Massive Subscriptions.
Schmeckt denn der Tee grad so komisch?
Warte mal.
So.
Wahrscheinlich einfach, weil er kalt ist.
Gut, lass uns mal auf YouTube reingucken, was haben wir denn so?
Was verdient ein
Band? Okay, komm, wir gucken das neue
Fireship-Video, Leute.
Weil Fireship-Videos sind immer nice.
Die 200-Stände-Verbindungsabbrüche,
weil VDSL, weil der Prozessor...
Oh, Schrott.
Ja, vielleicht ist dann tatsächlich der neue
Fritzbox gar nicht so verkehrt.
Ich verstehe, es ist blöd, was zu
kaufen, wovon man enttäuscht wurde, aber
insgesamt sind die Dinger echt nicht übel.
Okay.
Haben wir schon drüber gesprochen, letzten Stream, ja. Sehr nice.
Ich fürchte, da muss ich kurz was zu sagen, so nice das ist, dass vor allem der Workstation jetzt kostenlos ist für Privatanwender, ich fürchte, das ist ein Zeichen dafür, dass vor allem der Workstation aufs Abstellgleis gestellt wird.
Es hat sich die letzten Jahre über schon an vor allem der Workstation wenig getan und jetzt ist halt die Frage, ob sich da überhaupt noch was dran tun wird.
Was sehr bedauerlich wäre, weil vor allem der Workstation die beste Desktop.
Virtualisierungstechnologie ist und wir brauchen ordentliche Desktop-Virtualisierung, dass man zum Beispiel sowas hier machen kann.
Aber es erzeugt eine Menge Komplexität in deinem Code.
Ja und Threading in Python ist so merkwürdig, irgendwie, ich habe mich damit nur am Rande beschäftigt, aber ich lese immer, wenn man, wenn man ums Thema Multithreading und Python sich anguckt, da hast du immer sau viele Fallstricke, es gibt irgendwie drei Möglichkeiten, was zu machen und das eine ist dann tatsächlich nur unter der Haube Multithreader, dabei ist es weiterhin eigentlich auf einem Core und das andere ist super weird auf jeden Fall.
Es gibt alle Art von Gotchas.
Ja, komplett random.
Was? Hat jemand mit irgendeiner anderen Programmiersprache gerechnet?
Gut, ja, trotzdem auch nicht.
Ja, But now let's see what this looks like from a performance standpoint.
When I try to run this algorithm on a single thread, it takes forever, like 10 minutes or more.
However, I can run the same code without any modification whatsoever with the bend run C command.
When I do that, it's now utilizing all 24 threads on my cell.
Das ist schon nice, ja? Das muss man mal sagen, das ist schon nice.
Und wisst ihr, wie das noch besonders nice wäre?
Wenn man Bend ordentlich interfacen könnte mit anderen Programmiersprachen.
Was man wahrscheinlich kann, wahrscheinlich kannst du das FFI-mäßig über C, irgendwelche C-Exports oder so ansprechen.
Dann könnte das richtig ultra mega nice sein, wenn du was hast, was sich gut parallelisieren lässt.
Und vielleicht auch Sachen, von denen du in deinem Hirn gar nicht weißt, dass sie sich gut parallelisieren lassen.
Stell dir mal vor, du hast jetzt irgendwas, irgendeinen kleinen Teil deiner Anwendung, der halt sauviel CPU-Leistung braucht.
Und den lagerst du aus in ein Bend-Programm, ja, lässt das kompilieren, whatever.
Rufst das über irgendein C-Interface auf und dann macht's das einfach in parallel.
Das könnte richtig nice sein.
Das kann nicht nur Recursion, das kann nur Recursion, wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
...with bend run-cu.
Und jetzt dauert dieser Code nur 1,5 Sekunden, um zu runen.
Und ich werde einfach den Mikrofon runterladen.
Das war der Code-Report, danke für's Zuschauen und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal.
Bend, F-F-I-C.
Bend Language.
Massively Parallel High-Level Programming Language.
Ja, also so wie ich das verstanden hab, wandelt der das um, bis dort ganz viele parallelisierbare Instruktionen rauskommen.
Ich hab...
Außer dem Video.
Ist auch noch nix da, zugeguckt.
Okay, ähm, kann man?
Colony not working on Windows, ja, pff, ist mir egal.
Also ich hätte, ich würde jetzt vermuten, dass die, das Bend selber nicht unter Windows funktioniert, aber dass der Output, also dann die Library oder das Binary oder das, das auch schon unter Windows funktioniert, oder?
Kann man, kann man Bend-Programme irgendwie per ansprechen aus anderen?
Aha, kann man auch.
Okay, ist aber geplant.
Moment, Moment, mir geht's jetzt nicht da drum.
Okay, man kann Bend wohl noch nicht ansprechen, über andere, aus anderen Sprachen.
Das, doch, oder?
Ja, das müssen wir mal beobachten, es hört sich echt ganz spannend an.
Was dann nochmal so toll jetzt kann, also, so wie ich das verstehe, kannst du damit halt Probleme, von denen du in deinem Hirn nicht in der Lage bist, sie ordentlich zu parallelisieren,
parallelisieren lassen.
Alternativ, äh, nicht nur auf der CPU ausführen, sondern eben direkt auch auf einer Grafikkarte, was das nicht einfach nur doppelt, dreifach, vierfach, fünffach, sechzehnfach so schnell macht, sondern tausendmal, tausendfach so schnell.
Ne, das hat mit PyTorch nichts zu tun.
Das finde ich ganz spannend, also, das müssen wir uns mal im Hinterkopf behalten.
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Das.
Oh, das guck ich immer gerne.
Das ist immer so, so unsinnig überragend.
Das ist immer so unsinnig überragend.
Nicht überflüssig, aber nett anzugucken.
Yesterday.
Das haben wir uns doch schon angeschaut jetzt.
Man kann die Grafikkarte anstelle der CPU benutzen.
Also, so wie ich das verstanden habe, kannst du ein Programm in Bend programmieren oder ein Problem in Bend beschreiben, wie auch immer man es besser nennt.
Was schon mal den Vorteil hat, dass du dir ums Parallelisieren selbst keine Gedanken machen musst.
Also, du musst dir nicht selbst überlegen, wie kannst du es parallelisieren.
Du schreibst das mehr oder weniger so, wie du dir es denkst.
Bend parallelisiert das für dich, also transformiert deinen Code, so dass er gut parallelisierbar ist.
Und dann kannst du ihn entweder Single Threaded ausführen, Multi Threaded auf der CPU oder super krass Multi Threaded auf der GPU.
Das ist keine AI-Version.
Der hört sich schon immer so an.
Schon bevor es AI gab.
Aber der hat seine Stimme mittlerweile, glaube ich, ver...
Wie heißt das?
Versprachmodeln lassen, dass andere Leute Videos machen können, die sich so anhören wie er.
Ne, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Du kannst dann wahrscheinlich Bend aus JavaScript aufrufen demnächst.
Was sicherlich für so Unternehmen wie Discord beispielsweise ganz cool ist.
Stellt euch mal vor, Discord würde irgendein Feature anbieten, was super krass CPU-intensiv ist.
Mir fällt jetzt leider kein gescheites Beispiel an.
Ja, gehen wir mal von aus, Discord würde irgendwie anbieten...
Was könnte Discord denn anbieten, was super, super krass GPU-intensiv ist?
Und was nicht AI-Zeug ist?
Ja, Statistik oder sowas.
Ja, gehen wir mal von aus, Discord würde irgendwie anbieten, dass ihr irgendwelche Message-Statistiken oder whatever machen könnt.
Und das machen die nicht serverseitig bei sich, sondern bei euch auf dem Client.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ihr das macht, müsst ihr 5 Minuten warten, bis Discord fertig ist.
Und die könnten jetzt, die könnten quasi diesen Part in Bend programmieren.
Könnten dann das aufrufen und es wird entweder auf eurer GPU ausgeführt, wenn die supportet ist, oder multithreaded auf eurer CPU.
Und das ist dann nicht in 5 Minuten fertig, sondern in 3 Sekunden.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ein Bitcoin-Miner ein gutes Beispiel ist für...
Na doch, könnte, zumindest, zumindest...
Hash-Such-Part könnte eventuell nice sein dafür.
Wobei Bitcoin halt eh unsinnig ist, auf GPUs und CPUs zu minen.
Aber das muss man sich mal im Hinterkopf behalten.
Ich finde, das ist eine coole Sache.
Okay.
So, komm, wir gucken jetzt.
6 Lego-Vehicles vs. 6 Obstacles.
Obstacles, Obstacles, ich kann das nicht aussprechen.
Hindernisse.
Sagen wir einfach mal.
Obstacles.
Eine High-IQ-Konstruktion schon mal.
Ja, nice.
Easy.
Sieht reichlich umständlich aus, das Drehen.
Das klappt doch im Leben, wollte ich gerade sagen.
Also ich glaube, wenn hier ein bisschen Gummi unten an den Füßen wäre, könnte das durchaus funktionieren.
Okay.
Nee, das klappt nicht.
Gut.
Das Ding sollte mit den Abgründen am Anfang überhaupt kein Problem haben, aber das kommt auch nicht...
Nee, das kommt auch nicht über die Wand drüber, glaube ich nicht.
Und wo das Ding richtig Probleme mit haben wird, ist die...
Die Schräge hochzurollen oder nicht runterzurutschen.
Ja, das wird nix.
Ja.
Übrigens, das Ding dürfte laut Flacherdlern ja nicht funktionieren, weil Gravitation...
Und so, das gibt's ja nicht.
Okay.
Das Ding schafft die Schräge wahrscheinlich easy.
Also diese, weil es Gummi-Räder hat.
Ist das sinnlos?
Ja, diese Videos sind mega sinnlos.
Ja, aber ich guck die gerne.
Aber was das Ding nicht schafft, ist...
Ja, das schafft's easy.
Was das Ding nicht schafft, ist der normale...
Äh, ja, der normale Graben zwischen den zwei Platten.
Da fällt's runter.
Das schafft's...
nicht.
Ich hätte gedacht, das schafft's...
Das schafft's, ja.
Das hätte ich jetzt vermutet.
Die Wand schafft's nicht.
Das schafft's nicht.
Ja.
Äh, rumdrehen wird's auch nicht schaffen.
Oder wird's schaffen?
Doch, doch schafft's.
Okay.
Das war eher ein Skill-Issue des Drivers.
Okay, das wird nix.
Okay.
Das Ding sollte keinen...
Das hat Gummi und das Ding sollte die Schräge schaffen.
In beide Richtungen.
Die Wand schafft's auf jeden Fall nicht.
Und...
Die Abgründe...
...wird das...
...weiß ich nicht.
Ich frage, ob's lang genug ist.
Hä?
Gibt's?
Das...
Ja, genau.
Das andere schafft...
Oh, ob's das sch...
Ja, das schafft's auch.
Nope.
Nicht easy.
Das schafft's...
Okay, da hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht,
da ist es geradezu wie gemacht für easy.
Schafft's das.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich einfach nicht schwer genug.
Hat nicht genug Druck da unten drauf.
Ja, das wird nix.
Korgas.
Leichtes.
Das schafft's auch.
Das...
Ist so kurz.
Aber es sieht...
Es sieht so aus, als ist es breiter als das.
Das sollte es auch schaffen, ja.
Oh, nope.
Ja, da ist es nicht schnell genug für.
Und das geht auch nicht.
Ich weiß echt nicht, warum wir uns das angucken.
Aber irgendwie gucke ich die Videos geil.
Jetzt wird der advanced shit rausgeholt hier.
Okay, lass mich raten.
Das Ding packt jetzt alles.
Ja, mit den Gummi-Rädern sollte kein...
Sollte kein Problem sein.
Okay.
Das wird's schaffen.
Das ist ja quasi gemacht dafür.
Das muss schneller sein.
In der Geschwindigkeit klappt es nicht.
Aber mit ein bisschen Schmackes, wie man so schön sagt hier,
geht das.
Okay, mal gucken, was als nächstes kommt.
Ach nee, das wird jetzt verbessert.
Okay.
Ich hätte es gedacht, er macht's einfach schneller,
dass es da rü...
Ups, dass es da rüberspringen kann.
Passt mal auf, mit den fetten Rädern
packt's jetzt irgendwas anderes nicht mehr.
Ja, Speed.
Boah, Action pur.
Hä, das sag ich doch.
Es packt jetzt irgendwas anderes nicht mehr.
Mich hätte jetzt interessiert, wenn es kleinere Räder hätte.
Wieder die kleinen Räder, aber mehr Geschwindigkeit.
Ob's dann einfach gehen würde.
Er hat's schneller gemacht und größere Räder dran.
Also er hat quasi die Übersetzung ausgetauscht an den Rädern und die Räder.
Und, und, äh, fettere, stärkere Motoren drauf gemacht.
Ahhhh.
Knapp.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Guck mal hier.
Alter.
Ach, komm.
Lassen wir ihn gucken.
Das ist ein kompletter...
Och, nicht schon wieder so ein Ding.
... Home-Server, beziehungsweise NAS mit 10 TB Speicherkraft.
Alles...
Die Dinger gibt's doch an laufendem Band überall mittlerweile.
Also bei denen noch nicht, aber...
... habe ich mir selbst zusammengebastelt...
Ich...
Sogar ich hatte mal so ein Teil bei mir auf...
... auf dem Channel, wobei...
... nicht so ein Teil, das stimmt nicht.
Ich hatte eins mit.
Ähm...
Top Ryzen CPU und, äh, Grafikkarte.
Für Emulationskram.
Das ist eh...
Das ist so ein passiv gekühles Ding.
Na gut.
Wie kriegst du denn so ein kleines Teil 10 TB rein?
Im Prinzip...
... hast du Platz für...
... eine NVMe SSD eventuell?
Äh, SATA?
Ist die Frage.
Wie viel?
Weil rein mit...
Also mit zwei Sachen geht das, aber wird knapp.
Ja.
Da musst du ja jeweils 4 TB SSDs machen.
Das wird dann...
Geht dann ins, äh...
Also, sofern da nicht noch eine dritte reinpasst.
... Gehäuse und Mainboard sind von AliExpress.
Ja.
Ja, und das Teil kann ich einfach neben meinen Router stellen und...
China... China-Chinesen-Hardware.
... nicht mehr drüber nachdenken, weil das Ding ist komplett passiv gekühlt, macht keinen Mucks, hat keine...
... und nicht mehr drüber nachdenken, weil das Ding ist komplett passiv gekühlt, macht keinen...
Das ist bestimmt so ein Teil mit, ähm...
... Intel J...
... oder N...
... 4000... irgendwas.
Diese, diese ollen...
... Embedded-CPU...
... Low-Power...
... Intel-Dinger.
... hat keine mechanischen Festplatten drin...
... und 10 TB sollten noch ein paar Jahre reichen.
Und schnell genug ist es definitiv auch.
Hier lass ich grad ein lokales KI-Sprachmodell drauf.
Ja, brauch keinen.
Ja, und guck mal, hier kopier ich grad...
Also, wozu?
... eine Datei von meinem Windows-Rechner.
... und72 GB von meinem Windows-Rechner ab.
... und 72 GB von meinem Windows-Rechner ab.
Ordentlich.
Ok.
Also hat das Ding...
... 2,5 GB, ähhh...
... Schnittstellen?
... auf den Home-Server.
290 MB die Sekunde.
Kann man machen, oder?
Na, für Filme ist das nix.
Für Filme ist der SSD-Speicher viel zu teuer.
Ja.
Und, wie gesagt, alles komplett passiv gekühlt, kein einziger Lüfter eingebaut, und die
Leistungsaufnahme liegt im Leerlauf bei unter 11 GB.
Was haben so viele kritisiert, dass es nicht redundant ist, dass die Glauber einen gepinnten
Kommentar gewonnen haben?
Das würde ich ganz...
Ich gucke mir das Video an, das ist wahrscheinlich
nichts, was ich bei so einem Setup kritisieren würde,
weil im Zweifelsfall
ist, je nachdem, was die damit meinen,
ob die sowas wie ein RAID 1 meinen,
finde ich gar nicht mal so
sinnvoll bei sowas. Ein Backup
ist tatsächlich sinniger, ja,
beispielsweise USB,
noch eine klassische
Magnetfestplatte dran
und dort einmal in der Nacht
ein AirSync drauf gemacht. Muss kein AirSync sein,
man kann irgendein x-beliebiges Tool nehmen
ist wahrscheinlich die bessere Variante,
als den Speicherplatz zu halbieren mit einem RAID.
Was? Wo ist der Haken, fragt ihr euch?
Ja, seht ihr in diesem Video,
aber Spoiler schon mal, der Haken ist
klein genug, dass ich das Teil auf jeden Fall
als meinen Homeserver weiter
betreiben werde.
Liebe Gäste, liebe Gäste,
Alter, das ist ein Träumer.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von
NordVPN. Cordaware
Best Zero verbindet Menschen mit ihren
Apps, egal ob ihr nun
digitale Nomaden, Dienstleister
oder Unternehmens-Admin seid.
Mit Best Zero könnt ihr einfach und sicher auf
Anwendungen zugreifen und diese anderen
bereitstellen. Und wenn ihr jetzt denkt, ja,
okay, per VPN oder was? Ne,
Cordaware Best Zero ist kein
VPN, sondern
einfach das Thema Heim-
Genau, ja, ja.
Sehe ich genauso, Chat.
... Heim-Server schrägstrich
nass. Finde ich persönlich
zurzeit super spannend und wenn ich eure
Kommentare richtig deute,
ihr auch. Ja, und ich glaub, das liegt auch
daran, weil's da viele Fragen gibt.
Eine der Hauptfragen ist, was nimmt man für
Hardware für so'n Ding? Da gibt's bei mir ein ganz
wichtiges Kriterium. Darf das Ding
Lärm machen oder nicht? Bei mir
auf jeden Fall nicht. Also bei mir
darf es bisschen Lärm machen,
weil ich hab so'n kleinen,
hab ich euch ja schon gezeigt, ne, also
so'n kleinen,
klein abgeschotteten Raum, hier
sieht man's ja, hier geht's rein, aber
das ist nicht, es ist jetzt nicht super schallgedämmt,
ja? Also im Prinzip sind das hier ein paar
dünne, dünne Gipswände und ne Tür.
Also ein bisschen Krach darf's
bei mir machen, dann hört man das nicht.
Ich kann jetzt da keine...
Ich könnte da kein Playcenter
mit 100% Lüftern reinstellen.
Das würde
ich hier auch hören.
... ganz persönliches Problem mit den meisten
Nassen. Also wenn man irgend so was Fertiges kauft,
die haben halt immer Lüfter und
die laufen in den meisten... Die haben auch meistens so
kleine, hässliche Lüfter.
Ja?
Moment, macht das übrigens hier mein
AI-Voicefilter? Macht das
das raus, wenn ich Lüftergeräusche nachmache?
Nein, macht's nicht. Okay.
Ja, und so
hören sich ja die ganzen kleinen Furzlüfter an,
die sind... Sind das...
Sind das 12 Millimeter? Nee.
Was haben die da? Diese ganz kleinen 20 Millimeter
Lüfter. Die haben billige
und kleine Lüfter.
Sind...
Schrott, meistens.
Nervig.
Ja, das... Also, wenn's
die Möglichkeit gibt,
immer nice.
... auch permanent. Und es gibt
ja dann viele Leute, die sagen, ja, wenn's
dich nervt, stell das Ding doch in den Keller oder
in die Besenkammer. Aber das ist
dann halt der Clash der Lebensrealitäten.
Ich wohne in einer Mietwohnung,
ich hab keinen Keller mit Steckdose,
geschweige denn Internet und
ne Besenkammer auch nicht. Ich hab nen Keller,
aber da ist die Luftfeuchtigkeit so hoch,
dass ich der... dass ich dem
Ding keine... dass ich das
nicht irgendeiner langhaufenden Hardware
da... dem aussetzen möchte.
An jedem... Erinnern ihr euch
noch dran? Haben wir das nicht im... Wo wir grad dabei sind.
Haben wir das nicht im Stream gemacht?
Den Lüfter in meinem Switch
getauscht? Hm.
Haben wir das nicht im
Stream gemacht? Vielleicht
hat's das nicht ins Archiv geschafft aus irgendeinem...
Weil ich irgendwas geleakt hab oder so vielleicht.
Ja, und zwar, ich hab ja so ein
ES16XG
und...
da hab ich mir eigene
Adapter
gedruckt, 3D gedruckt.
Ja! Ja!
Genau so! Genau so haben wir das.
Das hab ich... Genau das hab ich gemacht bei mir.
Ja.
Genau das. Genau das.
Und ich bilde mir ein, das haben wir
in nem Stream gemacht.
Ich bilde mir ein, das haben wir im Stream gemacht.
Kann auch sein,
dass ich das ein bisschen durcheinander bringe.
Ja, und da konnte man dann die größeren
Lüfter da drauf machen.
Weil so kleine gab es keine.
Hast du
echte UniFi-Hardware im Einsatz?
Das ist keine UniFi-Hardware, das ist ein Edge-Switch.
Das ist eines mit eigener Management-
Oberfläche und nicht UniFi-Crap.
Ich hab alles UniFi-mäßige rausgeschmissen
in der Zwischenzeit. Und den hier hatte ich schon
bevor ich überhaupt mit UniFi-Sachen angefangen hatte.
Das ist eines der
besten Netzwerk-Hardware-Sachen,
die ich mir in den letzten Jahren gekauft hab. Das Ding funktioniert
einfach. War vor die
damalige Zeit gar nicht mal so teuer.
Na klar kann man sich jetzt drüber beschweren.
500 Euro-Switch, ja.
Aber das ist ein 10-Gigabit-Switch
mit 12 SFP-Plus-Ports
und 4 Kupfer-Ports.
Und die
SFP-Plus-Ports unterstützen natürlich auch
1 Gig, 2,5 Gig
und 10 Gig-Module.
Nein. Edge-Switch ist
nicht UniFi.
Edge-Switch ist Ubiquity.
Genauso wie UniFi.
Aber es ist nicht UniFi.
UniFi ist eine Produkt-
ja, wie nennt man das? Linie von denen.
Nicht das
gleiche, ne. Das eine ist der Hersteller, das eine
ist quasi eine Marke vom Hersteller.
Edge-Switch ES ist genauso eine Marke wie
UniFi. Ja, und das
hab ich bei mir auch im Switch
laufen. Und ja, man kann den
Switch danach noch zumachen. Zumindest meiner ist zu.
Was hast du gegen UniFi?
Oh, ich hab eigentlich nix wirklich großartig
gegen UniFi.
Ich mag's einfach nicht. Also,
eine Sache, die mich bei UniFi
nervt, ist, dass sie auf der einen Seite
sich an
Heim-Anwender richten wollen
und das auf der einen Seite so, sagen wir mal,
möglichst easy machen.
Aber das nicht konsequent.
Und dann
Sachen
anders benennen, als man's erwarten
würde, eher im Profi-Umfeld.
Also,
ich fand das nie,
das ist natürlich sehr subjektive Sache, ne,
ich fand das nie schlüssig von der
Aufmachung her, UniFi.
Und das größte Problem, was ich
mit UniFi hatte, war
gar nicht das, sondern,
dass die Features, die andere
Hersteller schon lange
haben, ewig nicht unterstützt
haben. Und das Hauptfeature,
was mich wirklich sehr genervt hat und
sehr gewurmt hat, dass UniFi
das nicht hat,
ist,
für das gleiche WLAN
mehrere Passwörter vergeben.
Für unterschiedliche Geräte. Also sprich, dass man
ein WLAN-Blub hat,
WLAN-SSID, Blub, ja.
Aber ich möchte,
dass Gerät 1 das Passwort
123456 hat und Gerät 2
ABCDEFG
als Passwort hat. Für das gleiche
WLAN. Und das ist
ein Feature, das können die meisten anderen
Hersteller, die jetzt, also wir reden jetzt nicht vom
16, 18 Euro
billig TP-Link Access Point,
aber alle etwas besseren
Hersteller können das, außer UniFi.
UniFi kann das mittlerweile auch
seit dreiviertel Jahr
oder so. Aber da hat
sich schon rausgeschmissen. Das hat
mich wirklich genervt. Weil das wollte ich
unbedingt haben. Und UniFi
hat es einfach jahrelang nicht auf die
Reihe gekriegt. Obwohl das alle anderen Hersteller,
sogar MikroTik,
sogar mit den billigen Access Points, kann
das. Wobei ich glaube, dass
die MikroTik-Implementierung ein bisschen
hakelig ist. Aber dafür ist das
Gramm deutlich günstiger.
OpenWrt kann es mittlerweile übrigens auch
ganz brauchbar.
Ich weiß nicht, ob über das Webinterface oder nur
über dieses WPA-File.
Aber wenn OpenWrt
das auf einem Billigrouter kann,
dann würde ich sagen, ey, sowas
dürfte UniFi auch einbauen.
Obwohl es dazu ja
schon ganz lange
Feature Requests
gab.
Und die wollten einfach
nicht. Mittlerweile
kann es UniFi.
Aber es ist sehr praktisch
ein WLAN
zu haben mit mehreren Passwörtern.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ihr
viele IOT-Geräte, MatrixHD,
danke für den Sub, zum Beispiel, wenn ihr
viele
IOT-Geräte habt, dann
braucht ja jedes
IOT-Gerät quasi euer WLAN-Passwort.
Und wenn es da nur
ein WLAN-Passwort gibt,
dann habt ihr halt das Problem,
wenn ihr das mal ändern wollt,
dann müsst ihr das auf allen Geräten
ändern. Ja, was teilweise
Ding der Unmöglichkeit ist, weil man irgendwie
60 IOT-Geräte hat und die sonst wo
verteilt hat. Und wenn ihr eins
dieser Geräte mal wegschmeißt, dann liegt
quasi weiterhin
im Flash
von diesem Gerät irgendwo in eurem Müll
euer WLAN-Passwort.
Zwei Sachen, die ich nicht schön fand.
Und
was man halt mit
mehreren WLAN-Passwörtern
pro Gerät, fürs gleiche WLAN
wohlgemerkt,
easy ändern kann.
Und viele Hersteller das auch schon unterstützen, aber
bei
Unify hat man sich da einfach
jahrelang Zeit gelassen und es sah so aus, als wird
das nie unterstützt. Bis es irgendwann
vor einem dreiviertel Jahr oder so, dass wir
ein Firmware-Update eingefügt haben.
Ja, wenn man mehrere Sachen verwaltet, ist das
sicherlich cool, dass man
mehrere Standorte und mehrere
Gebäudeinstallationen
und sowas da drüber verwaltet.
Und diesen Verwaltungsaspekt mag das ganz cool sein,
aber das, ja,
trifft für mich hier im Haus
mit ein paar Access-Points, macht's das nicht aus.
Zumal, die Access-Points, die ich
jetzt habe, die haben auch
ein Management-Dashboard, aber halt
Build-In in den Access-Points.
Warum sollten, hä?
Was juckt
den Access-Point, ob du einen
Shielded oder nicht Shielded Kabel hast?
Sperrst du auch den Internetzugriff
der Geräte? Kommt drauf an,
in welchem WLAN du drinnen bist.
Wenn du im
IoT-WLAN
bist, dann darfst du nicht ins Internet.
Bei mir dürfen Geräte im IoT-WLAN
weder miteinander reden,
noch mit dem Internet reden.
Die dürfen nur sich connecten auf
den MQTT-Server, wenn sie die Credentials
dafür haben und auf NTP.
NTP-Zeit abrufen dürfen sie auch, weil
sonst haben manche Geräte Probleme.
Das ist das einzige, was bei mir im IoT-WLAN erlaubt ist.
Und wenn ich ein Gerät wegschmeiße,
dann wird das einfach
gelöscht.
Und dann kann ich es wegschmeißen.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Okay, das ist ja sehr merkwürdig,
dass den das überhaupt interessiert, was für eine
Sorte Kabel daran angeschlossen ist.
So, gucken wir mal weiter.
Würde mich ein permanent rauschendes
NAS bzw. Home-Server
doll nerven. Wer aber natürlich
in so einem Einfamilienhaus wohnt, der oder
die kann sich da vielleicht schlecht eindenken,
weil da gibt's halt genug Orte,
wo man sowas ausstellt.
Ich wohne in einem Einfamilienhaus und
ich hab auch keinen gescheiten Ort
gehabt, deswegen musste ich einen bauen.
Lassen.
Ist ja auch nachvollziehbar.
Ist halt ein unterschiedliches Nutzungsszenario.
Naja, aber worauf ich hinaus will,
ich hab halt nicht so viel Platz und am allerliebsten
hätte ich halt einen Server.
Ja, aber was interessiert die das überhaupt?
Warum kann ein Gerät überhaupt
irgendwie das feststellen, ob das ein
geschirmtes Kabel ist oder nicht?
Weil ich mein, entweder liegt an den passenden
LANs, ähm, PoE
Zeug, 48 Volt an oder
nicht, also wie, warum interessiert die das überhaupt,
ob das Kabel geschieldet ist oder nicht?
... den ich mir einfach neben meinen
Router klatsche, Kabel dran
und dann nie wieder drüber nachdenken.
Zurzeit nutze ich einen gebrauchten,
passiv gekühlten FinClient,
an dem ein USB-Hub mit
vier 2,5 Zoll
5 TB Platten hängen. Das ist okay,
weil sich da kein Lüfter dreht und
die Platten sich runterfahren, wenn sie
länger nicht angesprochen werden, aber
gigant ist das nicht, allein weil
die Konstruktion so viel Platz einnimmt.
Außerdem ist mir das Kopieren auf das System
schon ein bisschen zu lahm. Ich schaff da so
80, im besten Fall 100
MB pro Sekunde, also A, weil
das halt langsame Platten sind und
B, weil nur 1 GB Anbindung.
Jetzt kommt hier der Mini-PC,
also meine neue Lösung, da stecken tatsächlich
10 TB drin und guckt mal,
wie viel weniger Platz das
einnimmt. Hier übrigens zum Vergleich noch ein
echtes NAS mit vier
3,5 Zoll Platten. Ja,
wirklich macht's vor allem eine Entdeckung
von mir. Ich wusste nämlich bis vor kurzem
nicht, dass es SSDs mit
8 TB gibt. Aber hier
von Samsung, als dann so langsam die Idee
für dieses Mini-NAS kam,
war das Teil sogar echt vergleichsweise
günstig. Das ist, äh, das ist
aber doch von Samsung,
da hab ich auch schon mal drauf geguckt,
ist das nicht eine KUVO?
Ja. Und hatten die KUVO-Dinger
nicht das Problem, dass
nach paar 100 MB
die Schreibrate übelst einbricht?
Irgendwas war doch
sass
an den KUVO-Dingern.
Per Firewall-Update, das war glaube ich
was anderes. Per Firewall-Update war
diese Sache mit, ähm,
schreibt sich selbst irgendwie so schnell kaputt.
Hab ich diesen Samsung
Disk Magic? Ja, hab ich noch drauf.
So grob 300 Euro.
Und leider ist die SSD jetzt auch
noch viel teurer geworden. Das ist auf jeden Fall
teurer als eine Magnetfestplatte,
aber der Unterschied... Die SSD
kostet das Doppelte von dem Rechner. Ist
zwar da, aber er ist exorbitant. Aber so ist es halt.
Also zumindest bei 300 Euro
war er das nicht. Jetzt schon, leider.
Naja. So, und obendrein
ist mir dann beim Ali,
das sagt ein CT-Kollege von mir immer,
und ich hab mir die ersten Male gedacht, dass das
so ein kleines Geschäft ist, wo er da immer hingeht,
wo er den Besitzer kennt, aber er meint
Ali Express, also
den chinesischen Riesenhändler.
Also jedenfalls, beim Ali hab ich
diese Kiste hier entdeckt. Das ist ein
Mini-PC von Topton
oder Topton mit Intel
N1. Ja, diesen PC gibt's wahrscheinlich
von 10
verschiedenen Herstellern mit eigenem Logo drauf.
Das ist ja bei diesen
China-Sachen oft so. Gerade wenn du bei Amazon
mal guckst,
die haben alle so diese typischen
China-Shop-Namen immer.
Und da kriegst du exakt
die gleiche Hose beispielsweise.
Acht mal,
zum Beispiel, wenn man hier
guckt, äh,
Outdoor-Hose.
Kurz.
Herren.
Ja, und dann wirst du feststellen, diese
diese Hose hier, ne?
Diese, diese Hose hier
gibt es von bestimmt
acht verschiedenen Herstellern. Die heißen dann so
was wie Vesponao,
Hyasospore,
Indico. Das sind alles, das sind
so, das sind die typischen China-Chinesen
Shop-Namen.
Ja, also wenn man
das jetzt mal aufmacht. Ich wette mit euch, das ist ein
China-Shop.
Hyasospore.
So.
Lasst mal gucken.
Das ist, das ist
ein, ich könnte wetten, das ist ein China-Shop.
Äh, wo kriegen wir das
jetzt raus, ob das ein China-Shop ist?
Gescheit.
Contact Us?
Ah, das ist irgendein Dropshipping-Zeug oder so.
Das sind so diese typischen,
diese typischen
China-Ding-Namen auf
auf Amazon.
Nicht alles, aber
das sieht jetzt, das sieht schon,
das sieht schon wieder so ähnlich aus.
Alles, guckte mal.
Gut, das ist irgendein Shopify-Ding
wahrscheinlich.
Also ich finde dann die gleiche Hose hier gefühlt 100 Mal.
Ja, und das ist, das ist bei
PC-Hardware auch so.
Bei AliExpress sitzt man auf jeden Fall deutlich
Windows 11 ist... Nein,
nicht Windows 11 jetzt.
Sitzt man bei AliExpress deutlich näher an der Quelle.
100 CPU und die ist
in Homeserver-Kreisen gerade
nicht angesagt, weil das Teil nur eine
TDP von 6 Watt hat.
Das bedeutet nicht, dass der ganze Rechner nur
6 Watt zieht, aber es ist halt auf jeden
Fall deutlich weniger als
andere CPUs, vor allem, weil der N100...
Aber guck mal, es ist genau das, was ich getippt
habe, was drauf ist.
Embedded Intel
J4, irgendetwas.
Dafür echt Leistung.
Davon hatte ich auch schon ein Board, oder
ich hab sogar noch hier welche liegen.
Sogar noch mehr als zwei Boards noch
davon liegen, aber nur Boards, ohne.
Rechner drum rum.
Das ist eine wirklich coole Plattform.
...fähig ist.
Dieser Top-Ton-Mini-PC hat drei
Eigenschaften, die ich für meinen
Homeserver sehr, sehr gerne hätte.
Keine Lüfter, komplett passiv gekühlt.
Das Alu-Gehäuse hat hier oben so
Kühlrippen. Neben einer M2-SSD
auch noch Platz für einen
2,5 Zoll SATA-Datenträger.
Also hier kann ich die gerade
erwähnte 8 TB Samsung
In diesem Video
SSD einbauen.
Und last but not least
2,5 Gigabit Ethernet-Anschluss.
Beziehungsweise sogar direkt vier
Stück davon. Konkret sind das
Intel i226V.
Ihr könnt euch damit also auch nut...
Solange es Intel-Netzwerkkarten sind, ist
immer nice. Intel-Netzwerkkarten werden unter
Linux immer super unterstützt.
...oder eine Firewall bauen. Obendrein hat
das Ding auch noch angenehm viele
USB-Buchsen, nämlich vier USB 2.0
und zwei USB 3.0-Anschlüsse.
Und tatsächlich auch sogar Slots für
SIM-Karten, also wenn man sein Internet
über... Moment.
4G und 5G
haben die unterschiedliche
SIM-Karten-Formate
5G, Keck, Alu.
...Mobilfunk bezieht.
Die habe ich aber nicht ausprobiert.
Den Top-Ton-Mini-PC gibt's
auch vorbestückt. Ah, deswegen die Modem, okay.
Ich habe den aber als
Barebone bestellt, also nur
mit CPU. Ich rechne euch hier mal
die Kosten für dieses System, was ich in
diesem Video benutze, vor. Also
59 Euro habe ich für die Mini-PC mit
Intel N100 bezahlt.
50 Euro für einen 16 GB
DDR5 RAM-Riegel, also
SO-DIMM ist das.
125 Euro für eine 2 TB
M.2-SSD. Genau genommen habe ich es
nicht bezahlt, sondern ich habe eine
M.2 von Teracle genommen, die in
der Redaktion halt rumlag. Und
Den Hersteller habe ich noch nie gehört.
Kennt ihr den Hersteller? Teracle?
550 Euro
für die 8 TB
SATA-SSD
von Samsung. Ja, finde ich
auch teuer, aber man kann die
8 TB SSD auch weglassen oder halt
eine kleinere einbauen. Mir ging's ja
in diesem Video vor allem darum, zu zeigen, dass
so ein unsichtbares NAS möglich
ist. Und ein NAS mit weniger als
10 TB fand ich irgendwie lame.
Und ja, deshalb beißen wir da mal
in den sauren Preisapfel.
Also 884 Euro
kostet das ganze System, wenn ihr das
nachkaufen wollt. Teuer, aber auch geil.
Sehen wir gleich. Ich wollte nur kurz nochmal
betonen, wenn ihr die 8 TB nicht
Also performance-technisch
ist das Ding auf jeden Fall
brauchbar dafür.
Ich habe ja mehr oder weniger das
gleiche CPU, gleiches, also
nicht gleiches Board, aber gleiche CPU auf
anderem Board mal benutzt.
Ist okay, weil
Intel glücklicherweise
bei dieser Board-Generation,
beziehungsweise halt auch bei dieser CPU-Generation,
das ist ja Embedded, da wird ja keine CPU draufgestöpselt,
die ist ja quasi draufgelötet.
Im Endeffekt gibt es ja nur Board und CPU
in einem.
Glücklicherweise dort schon ihre
Crypto-Extensions drauf hat.
Ohne Crypto-Extensions wäre das Ding
eine schlechte NAS-Plattform.
Dank Crypto-Extensions in der CPU
finde ich, ist es eine ziemlich gute NAS-Plattform.
Da kannst du nämlich deine Festplatte
auch voll verschlüsseln und
du hast kaum Leistungseinbußen.
Weil du halt
nicht Ver- und
Entschlüsselung beim Schreiben über das
Werk nebenbei von der CPU
machen musst, wobei
mit Crypto-Extensions macht sie CPU auch,
aber verursacht keine normale
und nicht so hohe normale CPU-Last.
Und dann kriegst du dann auch
deine 2,5 Gig
saturated.
Was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde ist,
ob es ein Dual-Core oder ein
Quad-Core ist.
Dual-Core wäre
mir etwas zu lahm.
Ja, RAID finde ich auch unsinnig, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich weiß, anscheinend haben sich ja wohl Leute
drüber aufgeregt.
Wir müssen uns gleich über die Kommentare heran gucken.
Ich finde das eigentlich sinnig, in der
Kombination es ohne RAID zu machen.
Es ist eh kein Platz mehr
für eine zweite Festplatte drinnen.
Und nachdem
im Heimbereich
ein Backup aus meiner Sicht viel
viel sinnvoller ist als ein RAID 1,
steht das bei dieser
Kiste ja keinem im Wege.
Weil der Unterschied, also der
grundsätzliche Unterschied dazwischen ist ja,
RAID 1 ist für Ausfallsicherheit,
Backup
ist für, sagen wir es mal,
Datensicherheit, falls man das so nennen kann.
Weil ein RAID 1
schützt dich nicht gegen
fehlerhafte Bedienung.
Also sagen wir mal, du gehst jetzt auf die Kiste
drauf und sagst rm-rf keckel,
danach ist
keckel weg.
Auf beiden Platten, weil es ist ein RAID 1,
es ist gespiegelt.
Wenn du ein Backup hast, so asynchron einmal
in der Nacht, kannst du die Datei löschen,
aber
im Backup ist er noch da.
Und nachdem die Ausfallraten
von solchen SSDs,
ziemlich gering sind,
dass du nicht damit rechnen musst, dass du alle paar Wochen
die SSD abkackst, das wäre ein ganz schön teures Vergnügen
auch, ist das ok.
Dann bestellst
du dir eine neue SSD, baust
sie ein und kopierst die Sachen aus dem Backup
wieder drauf, fertig.
Da hast du vielleicht mal einen Tag Ausfall, bis Amazon
kommt, oder wenn du in ein Geschäft
fährst, noch weniger.
Kannst ja auch theoretisch noch eine 8TB
baugleiche SSD daneben legen,
wenn du das ganz schnell haben willst.
Baust du das aus, baust die neue SSD ein,
kopierst die Sachen vom Backup drauf, bist
wieder da.
Also, ich sehe jetzt nicht so sehr,
wo es
das RAID 1 im Heimbereich
jetzt wirklich groß rausreißen
würde. Es ist nice to have,
das gebe ich zu, plus ein externes
Backup, wenn überhaupt dann immer,
dazu.
Also, erst ein Backup und dann
RAID 1 und nicht umgedreht.
Aber,
auch statistisch gesehen,
wird es jetzt einem nicht so viel
ersparen. Genau,
das ist ein sehr schönes Beispiel, Chatge.
Das ist ein sehr schönes Beispiel,
irgendwelche Verschlüsselungen, Ransomware,
Shit am Start
und es ist alles verschlüsselt, egal
ob RAID oder nicht. Klar gibt es
jetzt natürlich noch so ein paar Zwischendinger,
man könnte beispielsweise auch sagen,
man macht einen ZFS RAID
mit regelmäßigen Snapshots.
Wobei
die Snapshots auch Speicherplatz belegen,
also irgendwo muss es hin.
Dann hättest du beides ein bisschen kombiniert,
aber es ist ja vom Ansatz her
das gleiche.
Du hast einmal eine Spiegelung
für die Ausfallsicherheit und einmal
Snapshots, beziehungsweise ein Backup
für, hups, ich habe aus Versehen was gelöscht
oder es wurde was verschlüsselt und so.
Weiter.
Also, wenn euch das System
bei 2 TB reichen, dann kostet euch das System
334 Euro. Hört sich ja schon mal nicht so schlimm an.
Okay, der Zusammenbau erstmal.
Das war wirklich auch eine positive Überraschung.
Die Ali-Lieferung hat weniger als
eine Woche gedauert und das Ding
Das kommt wahrscheinlich
entweder aus einem EU-Warenlager,
also sprich
Spanien, Niederlande, Frankreich
oder so. Wir können doch gerade mal gucken.
Ich will mir das nicht kaufen,
aber
wir müssen es ja mal angucken.
Oder es kommt direkt mit dem Flugzeug.
Wobei, da hatte ich
ja auch letzten Spaß mit
dem Thema Flugzeug.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch das schon mal erzählt habe.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich es
in der App noch sehe.
Falls ich euch das schon erzählt habe,
dann sagt mir Recycled Story.
Aber
ich habe mir letztens aus China
was bestellt.
Puzzlemeister, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich habe mir letztens aus China was bestellt.
Ich habe mir letztens
eine Custom Platine
PCB anfertigen lassen.
Und passt mal auf,
was das Ding für merkwürdige
Wege genommen hat.
Also
Wo ist es denn?
Moment
Wo habe ich es denn?
JLCPCB
Kann das sein, dass sie es nur per E-Mail
geschickt haben oder so?
Hier ist es.
Okay, also.
Shipment, Shipment Updates.
Also es ging los.
Es ging los in
China. Und zwar
China People's Republic
Shuangxiang
Delta
Area.
Dann ging es weiter dort
Irgendwann kam es in Hongkong raus.
Und dann ging es von
Hongkong ins Flugzeug.
Dann
ist es dort irgendwie durch das
Clearance.
Dann kam es in Leipzig raus.
So, dann kam es in Leipzig raus.
Leipzig und Zoll und DHL habe ich ja schon
schon öfters mal
negative
Erfahrungen gemacht. Gerade mit Bestellungen aus den USA.
So, Leipzig. Okay, dann ist es in Leipzig.
Und dann liegt es einfach einen Tag in Leipzig rum.
Und dann denkst du dir so, ja was macht es denn
in Leipzig? Man weiß es nicht.
Dann kommt irgendwann eine Nachricht.
Es ist Recycle Story.
Ich habe es schon erzählt. Egal.
Dann liegt es einen Tag in Leipzig rum und steht auf einmal da
Shipment is on hold.
So, und dann
einen Tag später gucke ich in die
Sendeverfolgung. Oh, das ist
aber gut hier. Haben sie sich
übertroffen. Bei mir hat es nicht geklappt.
So, da gucke ich. Also das war
noch im April. So, da gucke ich
in die Sendeverfolgung. Es war schon in Leipzig
wohlgemerkt. Das war von China nach Leipzig.
So, und da gucke ich nach.
Nächster Eintrag.
Es ist in Kanada.
In Quebec.
Oder wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Quebec. Kanada.
Also es ist von China nach Leipzig.
Wo es dann hätte nach Frankfurt gemusst.
Es ist nach Kanada.
Von Kanada.
Quebec.
Quebec. Wie auch immer.
Danach ist es von Kanada
nach
Ich habe auch schon wieder vergessen wie es heißt.
Kinikina
Dati
USA, Ohio
Danach ist es East Midlands
UK
Und dann ist es wieder. Haltet euch fest.
Danach ist es wieder in Leipzig
eingetroffen.
Und dann ging es
Dann ging es von Leipzig
nach Frankfurt. Und dann kam es
bei mir an.
Das Paket ist
legit einmal um die Welt.
Ihr müsst euch überlegen. Das ist von
China nach Leipzig
nach Nordamerika
nach UK
nach Deutschland.
Das ist einmal ein super effizienter Transport.
Das ist einmal gratis um die Welt.
Noch mal zusätzlich.
Genau.
Da wusste jeder Geheimdienst noch schnell eine Wand zu einbauen.
Die Engländer
haben dann zum Schluss gesagt. Ey ich will auch noch.
Versand
Versand war glaube ich sogar
Ne Versand war nicht kostenlos.
Bei JLC, PCB
Aber es war billig.
Es war auf jeden Fall billig.
Und ich habe im Endeffekt 20 Euro bezahlt.
In Afrika war es nicht.
Es liegt aber auch nicht so irgendwie auf dem Weg.
Gut.
Kanada auch nicht.
Wobei Kanada würde auf dem Weg liegen wenn man andersrum fliegt.
Wie lange hat es gedauert?
Ja es war leider 1. Mai Feiertag noch dazwischen.
Es kam am 3. Mai
kam es an.
Am 3. Mai und losgeschickt wurde es
am
28. April.
Ohne Feiertag dazwischen wäre es schneller da gewesen.
Ich habe es extra so bestellt, dass es noch vor dem Feiertag ankommt.
Aber DHL hat sich ja gedacht.
Nope Max du kriegst es nicht.
Es muss einmal quer über die halbe Welt geschickt werden.
Ja gut.
Whatever.
Zumindest war es billig.
20 Euro habe ich bezahlt für 5 Boards.
5 Custom PCBs.
Und die PCBs sehen folgendermaßen aus.
Ja.
So sehen die zum Beispiel aus.
Schönes Vorschaubild.
Nice 5 Head Archive.
Ja so sehen die PCBs aus.
So kamen die 1 zu 1 aus China an.
Also nicht mit dem Widerstand oben drauf.
Also nur dieses Board hier.
Und ich habe jetzt
eine nice neue Kamera für solche Streams.
Sehr nice.
Guck mal.
Wie das jetzt ausschaut.
Hier sieht man es.
Die Boards habe ich bestellt.
Die Platinen habe ich bestellt in China.
Also wirklich.
Ich bin da echt beeindruckt von
wie günstig das ist.
Wie schnell es insgesamt funktioniert hat.
Und wie ordentlich die Dinger
doch dann auch gefertigt sind.
Für 20 Euro.
Kann sich nicht beschweren.
5 Stück habe ich davon bestellt.
Hätte ich mehr bestellt
wäre es sogar anteilmäßig noch
deutlich günstiger geworden.
Das läuft
Das läuft auf einem eigenen Server
von Sibaro.
Die bei sich
fragt mich nicht.
Die haben da ganz abgedrehtes Zeug.
Die haben ein
eigenes IPv6
AS.
Also BGP Internet Routing Gedöns.
Worüber wir
jetzt per Cloudflare
IPv4 Traffic tunneln.
Hast du das Board schon
in die Klimaanlage eingebaut?
Ne.
Habe ich noch nicht.
Ich habe in einem Video gesehen wie das funktioniert.
Und leider muss man die Klimaanlage dafür
mehr auseinanderbauen als ich Bock drauf habe.
Zur Zeit.
Ich habe es noch nicht gemacht.
Okay.
Was wollte ich nochmal gucken?
Warum habe ich die Seite nochmal aufgemacht?
Achso von wo das losgeschickt wird.
Okay.
Lieferung.
Also wahrscheinlich kommt das wirklich aus China.
Wenn ihr das hier hinschreibt.
Normalerweise kann man den Versand ja auswählen.
Das
geht glaube ich aber nur
wenn man
eingeloggt ist.
Da gibt es ja verschiedene
Versandvarianten oftmals bei
AliExpress.
Und das kann man wahrscheinlich
nur auswählen wenn man eingeloggt ist.
Ist immer ein bisschen weird bei AliExpress.
Ja.
Garantierte Lieferung.
Das ist aber sehr nett, dass ich was kaufe und es dann auch bekomme.
Also.
Je nachdem was man da auswählen kann.
Ach hier.
Es ist ohne Mist.
Es ist jedes Mal
ein anderer.
Okay AliExpress Standard Shipping.
Jedes Mal ein
mir bis jetzt noch nicht bekannter
chinesischer Versanddienstleister.
Ich habe da bestimmt schon keine Ahnung
16 verschiedene oder so gehabt.
Die haben unendlich viele.
Welche Zahlungsoptionen?
Meistens Paypal wenn Paypal möglich ist.
Ich habe auch einen
Alipay Account. Den musste ich mal irgendwann machen
vor zig Jahren als man dort noch
hauptsächlich per Alipay bezahlt hat.
Das ging dann so. Du hast Alipay
Du hast Paypal. Nein.
Du hast Alipay mit Paypal verbunden
und dann hast du auf AliExpress mit Alipay bezahlt.
Guck mal DHL.
25 Euro Versand. 10. Juni.
AliExpress Standard Versand.
Umsonst.
Das ist so heftig subventioniert
teilweise.
Aber natürlich nicht mein Problem.
Na gut. Gucken wir jetzt das Video fertig.
Machte dann auch wirklich einen sehr robusten Eindruck
mit diesem Voll-Alu-Gehäuse
und der Zusammenbau war tatsächlich auch
extrem easy. RAM-Riegel
reinklicken. M2
reinklicken und festschrauben.
2,5 Zoll SATA-SSD
an den Deckel schrauben. Das mitgelieferte
SATA-Kabel anschließen und das
Gehäuse zuschrauben. Also das schwierigste war
eigentlich auszuprobieren, wie man das SATA-Kabel
drehen muss, damit der Deckel
zugeht. Aber ja. 30 Sekunden
Sache. So und jetzt aber zur Performance.
Also erstmal anschalten.
Und falls ihr euch jetzt fragt, ob das mit dem
Gebote und dem Datenträger
auswählen alles easy geklappt hat oder
ob ich da erst Chinesisch für lernen musste.
Ne, das ist ein ganz normales
Army BIOS auf Englisch mit vielen
Einstellungsmöglichkeiten und alles
sehr normal. Also wenn ihr schon mal ein normales
Mainboard bedient habt, da fällt
hier jetzt nichts außergewöhnliches
auf. Auch das Auswählen des
Boot-Datenträgers, überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich hab dann erstmal meine USB-SSD
mit Armibios gekauft. Das ist
so eine Linux-Distribution
nur für Spiele-Emulation. Da hatten wir schon mal
ein Video zu gemacht. Und ja, das Ding
ballert. Also sogar die am schwierigsten
zu emulierenden PS2-Spiele
wie God of War 2, das
klappt auf Anhieb und recht
flüssig. Andere PS2-Spiele laufen
sogar in doppelter als der Original-Auflösung
mit stabilen 60 FPS.
Ja und natürlich sind auch Dreamcast
N64... Ja, wobei ich so
ein Ding halt echt nicht dafür kaufen würde.
...MQB und Wii U bei vielen
Spielen noch kein Problem. Aber kannst ja mal ausprobieren.
Also generell ist die Performance bei dem Teil
nochmal deutlich besser als bei einem
Raspberry Pi 5. Ja, das ist klar.
Ja und das wird auch unter Windows 11 deutlich.
Das hab ich nämlich danach auch mal
testweise installiert und den Benchmark
Geekbench 6 laufen lassen.
Da schafft der Mini-PC 3017
Multicore-Punkte. Mehr als
das Doppelte als der Raspberry 5.
Ja und hier noch das Resultat von
dem 3D-Mark Timespy.
Die Schwubbizität von Windows 11 war auch
wirklich gut. Das fühlte sich alles super an.
Was mich dann erstmal fast...
Man kauft sich das Ding halt auch nicht dafür.
War gespannt, wann endlich die Nass-Geschichte kommt.
...umgehauen hat, war, als ich mit Steam Cyberpunk
2077 installieren wollte.
86 GB sollten dafür
heruntergeladen werden. Und dann sagte Steam
irgendwas von 5 Minuten Ladedauer.
Und ich so, was? Hä? Ich hab da nur
eine Internetleitung mit einem Gigabit.
Wieso steht da was von 2,1
Gigabit? Hat der Ali-Rechner jetzt mal
eine Leitung direkt neu gemacht?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Zieht das von einem anderen
Rechner im Netzwerk, oder was?
Steam holt sich die Daten nicht aus dem Internet,
sondern von meinem Gaming-Projekt aus dem
lokalen Netz. Das steht da auch, wenn ich
hingeguckt hätte. Okay, hab ich zuerst nicht gecheckt.
Aber auf jeden Fall, das 2,5
Gigabit Ethernet hat sich schon mal gelohnt.
Das bringt wirklich was.
Kleiner Einschub hier. Es müssen natürlich alle
genutzten Geräte 2,5 Gigabit
unterstützen. Bei mir ist das so, dass meine
Fritzbox 6690
nur einen einzelnen 2,5 Gigabit
Anschluss hat. Deshalb hab ich mir noch
diesen Fünffach-Switch mit 2,5
Gigabit Unterstützung gekauft.
Und damit konnte ich dann den Mini-PC
nass und meinen Hauptrechner
anschließen. Also schön schnell
Daten übertragen, das geht schon mal.
Nice. Aber das ist dann irgendwann
hart eingebrochen bei der
Cyberpunk-Installation. Ich hab dann mal die
Temperatursensoren ausgelesen mit
hwinfo. Und ja, die M.2 SSD,
die schien mir der Übeltäter zu sein.
Da zeigte nämlich der Sensor am
SSD-Controller heftige
104 Grad an. Und der Hauptsensor
der SSD auch noch eher
unangenehme 82 Grad.
Und ja, ich vermute, das war so viel,
dass die SSD in so einen deutlich
langsameren Modus geschaltet ist.
Und das Problem tauchte übrigens auch beim
Installieren sehr vieler Windows-Updates auf.
Also auf einmal fühlte sich das System
gar nicht mehr so schwuppsig an.
Und überall hakte und
lahmte das. Ja, aber da
ich den Mini-PC aber ja als Home-Server
unter Linux, also konkret mit
ja, dass das passiv gekühlt war,
bei voller Pulle, dass das nicht
lange mitmacht, ist klar.
Das könntest du eventuell auch bei
bei längeren Datenübertragungen
haben, aber nachdem das den Crypto-Extensions
hat, sollte noch nicht mal
groß die Verschlüsselung
bzw. Entschlüsselung, je nachdem ob du drauf kopierst
oder runter kopierst, da die CPU
so an die Grenze
bringen, dass es überhitzt.
Wobei es halt sich nur runter
taktet. Das kackt ja nicht ab.
Ja, bei solchen passiven
gekühlten Dingern ist das halt oftmals so.
Wie gesagt, das ist beim Raspberry Pi
ähnlich. Mein Lieblings
mein Lieblings Raspberry Pi Case
ist ja das hier. Gibt's schon mehrere
Generationen von.
Weil das ein großer passiv gekühlter
Alu-Block ist. Du machst so ein Ding
hier dann auf die CPU
und
wobei ich mir beim Raspberry Pi immer nicht
merken kann, was GPU und was CPU ist.
Das da wahrscheinlich.
Und das ist dann auch so, wenn du das
Ding laufen lässt,
für 20 Minuten volle Pulle,
dann wird das auch ziemlich warm.
Und selbst wenn du das Gehäuse anfasst, ist es
unangenehm mit der Hand anzugreifen.
Was man natürlich sicherlich
machen kann ist, wenn man
wenn ich mir dieses Gehäuse hier so angucke,
dann hat es ja so ein paar
Fake-Kühlrippen.
Also wenn man das Gehäuse
wo stehen hat, wo ein bisschen Luftfluss
drum rum ist, dann könnte ich
mir vorstellen,
dass das
durchaus einiges bringt.
Wenn ich mir das Gehäuse
laufen lassen wollte, bin ich nicht ins
Windows Troubleshooting eingestiegen.
Ich wollte zuerst mal wissen, ob das vielleicht unter
Linux gar nicht erst passiert.
Was ich aber vorher noch gemacht habe,
ich habe so ein billiges Heatsink für 5 Euro
auf die M2 draufgeschnallt.
Also wie läuft das Ding als Server?
Also erstmal das Unraid-Image auf dem Stick
und los.
Der Heatsink wird ja auch nicht viel bringen ohne Luftfluss da drinnen.
Das sorgt vielleicht dafür, dass es ein bisschen
länger braucht, bis es heiß wird.
Wieder beeindruckend.
Wie schnell und unproblematisch
Unraid funktioniert.
Und nein, ich werde nicht dafür bezahlt.
Und ja, mich regt das neue Preismodell
von Unraid auch total auf.
Also auf jeden Fall hatte ich nach 2 Minuten
eine funktionierende
SMB-Freigabe.
Ich habe dann einen Ordner so eingestellt,
dass der ausschließlich diese
heißlaufende M2-SSD verwendet.
Und nicht die kühlere
SATA-SSD. Und da habe ich dann ungefähr
einen Terabyte übers Netzwerk draufgeschrieben.
Übrigens mit konstanten
280 MB pro Sekunde.
Also dreimal so schnell wie auf
meinem alten Home-Server mit Gigabit-Anschluss.
Das hat mich also schon mal gefreut.
Und die 280 MB pro Sekunde
werden übrigens auch auf der
8 TB SATA-SSD übers Netz erreicht.
So, aber ich wollte ja gucken, ob die
M2 überhitzt. Ich habe dann gleichzeitig
alle CPU-Kerne voll ausgelastet,
indem ich auf dem Home-Server
so einen lokalen KI-Chatbot
installiert habe, also als Docker-Container.
Harter Stresstest
Ich hätte ehrlich gesagt
einfach Stress gestartet.
Das ist so ein Kommando-Zeilen-Tool
zum CPU-Auslastung
generieren unter Linux.
Übrigens, sehr gut auch in Kombination
mit S2E.
Wer keinen Bock hat, Stress-Argumente
von Hand
einzustellen, der kann
S2E starten. Geht hier einfach auf Stress
und jetzt BÄM!
CPU-Auslastung 100%,
was ihr auch mit Hardtop seht.
BÄM! Volle Pulle.
Stream ist nicht F, das ist in meiner 4M
und die hat nicht genug CPUs, dass das Stream F ist.
Man kann hier natürlich auch noch einstellen,
was man machen will, wie viele Work-Accounts
oder whatever. Aber für einfach mal
aber für einfach mal kurz
die Kiste auslasten
dürfte das die einfachste Variante unter
Linux sein. Stress in den S2E installieren,
hier anklicken,
also einfach mal Enter drücken an der Stelle,
hier kannst du umschalten inzwischen, nur gucken wie viel ist
und die ganze Auslastung verursacht. BÄM!
Und man kann jetzt
natürlich auch sagen, ey ich will ein Summary und
wir machen plus 4 zum Beispiel
und dann gehen wir hier auf Stress
und dann, ups,
was hab ich nicht gespeichert?
2?
Ich bin zu unfähig dafür,
das zu bedienen.
100% CPU-Auslast.
Welcher Terminal-Emulator ist das?
Das Terminal hier, das ist
Westterm.
Und das wichtigste,
das wichtigste
Feature an Westterm ist,
es kann Bilder und GIFs
auf der Kommandozeile anzeigen.
Das heißt, man kann jetzt
eine Endlosschleife
Ayaya-GIFs machen.
Enorm wichtig.
Das ist das Killer-Feature schlechthin.
Und wenn man dann
Abbrechen drückt,
dann ist die Animation
geht trotzdem weiter.
Gekauft, ja, finde ich auch.
Das ist das wichtigste Feature
überhaupt.
Das kann man vergessen,
aber das zählt das Terminal.
Umgebungstemperatur.
Und das Resultat,
der Haupttemperatursensor auf der M2
hat maximal 79 Grad gezeigt.
Der Controllersensor auf der M2
blieb bei unter 90 Grad.
Und es waren keine relevanten Einbrüche
bei den Transferraten zu sehen.
Also, wenn die CPU-Auslastung hochging,
Können das andere Konsolen nicht?
Nö, die wenigsten können das.
Mir fällt eigentlich nix ein,
was das noch in dieser
guten Integration kann.
Es gibt noch
KITTY, das kann das,
aber KITTY hat andere Probleme.
Der KITTY-Autor ist ja der Meinung,
niemand verwendet TMUX über SSH
und solche komischen Dinger.
Ansonsten fällt mir nichts mehr ein,
was das noch kann.
Serious Max, kennst du den?
Hast du den schonmal ein paar Sachen
verwendet?
Den KITTY-Programmierer?
Ja, der ist ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Der ist richtig vielfältiger.
... wurde so heiß, dass ich das
ohne Schmerzen nicht länger als ein paar Sekunden
anfassen konnte. Gemessen habe ich
auf der Oberfläche über 50 Grad
und das ist tatsächlich oberhalb
der in der EU...
Da hätten wir jetzt wunderbar,
hätten wir das hier gemacht, hätten wir jetzt wunderbar
unseren selbst entwickelten
Temperatursensor verwenden können für...
Maschinenrichtlinie
festgelegten Verbrennungsschwelle
bei einer Minute Kontaktdauer.
Bei 10 Minuten sind das
sogar nur 48 Grad.
Also, das muss ich sagen, das finde ich unschön.
Ich fasse das aber natürlich normalerweise
nicht an, das Ding, aber ich habe trotzdem...
Aber es steht vielleicht auf einem Holz drauf.
Hitze und Elektronik
nicht so gut. Naja, aber zumindest
wenn der Homeserver gerade nichts macht,
kühlt sich das Gehäuse auch wieder ab.
Also, es ist immer noch warm, aber
dieses heftige Aufheizen passiert wirklich
nur beim Kopieren von großen Datenmengen.
Was ja nicht so häufig passiert.
So, aber jetzt wird es auch nochmal erfreulich.
Der selbstgebastelte Homeserver zieht
im Leerlauf mit Unraid
weniger als 11 Watt aus der Steckdose.
Und Leerlauf...
Das hatte ich mehr oder weniger mit...
Ich hatte ja hier ein sehr ähnliches
Board, hatte ich das auch, war unter 10 Watt.
Gerade wenn man mit PowerTop
noch ein paar Sachen einschaltet,
dann bist du deutlich unter 10 Watt.
Eitel. Das ist ein
sehr nicer Wert.
Irgendwie Ruhezustand oder so.
Das heißt, das Ding ist sofort da, wenn man es
anspricht von außen. Wenn ich was drauf
kopiere und gleichzeitig die CPU
auslasse, dann steigt die Leistungsaufnahme
auf maximal
28 Watt. Also maximal.
Und das ist weniger, als viele
konventionelle Nasse
im Leerlauf aufnehmen. Und übrigens
die 11 Watt Leerlaufleistung sind auch
weniger, als mein viel langsamerer
bisheriger Homeserver. Na gut, allein schon
in dem Zeug. Vier USB-Platten.
Der nimmt im Ruhezustand ungefähr
12 Watt. Und da müssen die Platten dann auch erst
aufwachen, also wenn man sie verwenden
will, was ein paar Sekunden dauert. Das ist
bei dem N100 Mini-Homeserver...
Aber SMA 8 vs 12
ist ja im Prinzip nichts.
SSD ist nicht der Fall.
Ja und generell muss ich sagen...
Weiß nicht, in Euro pro Jahr oder so.
Keine Ahnung, ich kann das schlecht schätzen.
Immer wieder, dass das Ding schneller ist als
mein alter Server. Also zum Beispiel schon bei der
Android-Oberfläche, das geht auf jeden Fall
zackiger. Okay, das ist ziemlich unwichtig,
aber man merkt das definitiv auch bei
dem lokalen Netflix-Plex.
Ach ja, was ich gucken wollte, war das jetzt eigentlich ein Quad-Core
oder nicht? Hups, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
War das jetzt ein Quad-Core oder nicht?
Ich denke mal, ich denke mal schon.
Ja, die Rechner sind enorm energieeffizient
geworden, was Idle angeht.
Äh...
Ist das ein Quad-Core?
Ja, ist es.
Ist es, nice.
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Also, da ist das, was ich gerne benutze.
Wenn man da ein Video
Dann nimmt im Ruhezustand
ungefähr 12 Watt und da müssen die Platten
dann auch erst aufwachen, also wenn man
sie verwenden will, was ein paar Sekunden dauert.
Das ist bei dem N100
Mini-Home-Server dank SSDs
nicht der Fall. Ja, und generell muss ich sagen,
merkt man auch immer wieder, dass das Ding
schneller ist als mein alter Server.
Also zum Beispiel schon bei der Android-Oberfläche,
das geht auf jeden Fall zackiger. Okay,
das ist ziemlich unwichtig, aber man merkt das
definitiv auch bei dem
lokalen Netflix-Plex,
was ich gerne benutze. Wenn man da ein Video
zum Beispiel auf dem Fernseher startet,
geht das schneller als beim alten Server
und skippen und spulen sowieso.
Das fühlt sich auch jetzt wirklich besser
als der alte Homeserver und auch besser als
alle Streaming-Dienstleister
wie Netflix und Amazon Prime, die ich so
kenne. Weil die Daten ja lokal im Netzwerk
liegen, ja, und flutscht super schnell.
Ja, 8 TB SSD, leider nur
eine Kuvo, wobei das ja
wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht, ja,
ne, ist auch praktisch gesehen
kein Problem ist,
weil die 2,5
Gigabit
wahrscheinlich eher das Limitierende
sind oder
gut, 2,5 Gigabit heißt,
man kann maximal theoretisch,
lass mal überlegen,
125 sind es bei Gigabit,
250 sind es bei 2,2
Gigabit und dann nochmal
die Hälfte obendrauf, also sagen wir nochmal
so 60, so 310
oder so
irgendwie, also
310 MB, Megabyte
die Sekunde, wären
bei 2,5 Gigabit jetzt so mal
aus dem Kopf so über den Daumen gepeilt
ungefähr maximal möglich.
Ja, dann beschränkt
vielleicht die SSD doch ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht,
was die Kuvo schafft
wirklich lange Zeit
kontinuierlich zu übertragen.
Mag sein, aber die Kuvo ist die einzige,
die es gibt nach Terabyte.
Also ich bilde mir ein, dass die Kuvo einbricht
nach einer Weile, nach so 1,
1, 2 Minuten volle Pulle
auf, ja, was weiß ich,
250, 300
MB.
Muss man sich jetzt Benchmarks angucken,
weiß ich aus dem Kopf auch nicht.
Zumindest ist das wahrscheinlich echt
ein ganz guter Match für die
Interface-Geschwindigkeit.
Dürfte ungefähr, also dürfte
nichts das andere großartig ausbremsen.
Zugespielt werden, also
richtig cool. Und generell kann man mit dem
N100 wirklich coole Sachen machen.
Von dem lokalen KI-Chatbot,
habe ich ja schon erzählt, aber ich habe zum Beispiel auch mal
Windows als Docker-Container in
Unraid installiert und da dann über den
Browser-VNC-Remote-Desktop
mäßig drauf zugegriffen. Das ist auch
tatsächlich mehr als ein Gag. Also wenn man zum Beispiel
nur Linux oder macOS benutzt
und nur unregelmäßig irgendwie
eine spezielle Software kurz unter Windows
verwenden will, dann kann man das über so ein
Docker-Windows auf dem Home-Server auf jeden Fall
machen. Mein Fakt.
Das ist ja eigentlich nicht wirklich...
Ich gehe ganz stark
davon aus, dass ihm das auch klar ist und das einfach
nur so im Video erwähnt wird, aufgrund der,
um das simpler darzustellen,
das ist ja gar kein
Docker-Windows. Das ist ja gar kein richtiges
Windows, was im Docker läuft.
Das ist ein KVM,
was
quasi, das ist ein
Docker-Image, was
ein fertiges Windows-Image
mitliefert, was dann in KVM
durch, was dann in KVM
gestartet wird,
was du durchreichen musst an Docker.
Also letztendlich ist es eine
KVM, die da gestartet wird
über dieses Docker-Image.
Es ist Docker,
in das du dein
lokales KVM passt,
also Dev-KVM
und im Endeffekt
bringt dieses Docker-Image halt nur
die Sachen mit, die du brauchst,
um
Windows laufen lassen zu können, also
irgendein Windows-ISO,
was bootbar ist und sowas, bringt das mit
und dann startet
es einfach eine KVM-VM.
So, wie wenn du es selbst
in KVM installiert hättest.
Also der Docker-Part
macht es eigentlich
nur einen Ticken einfacher und dass du nicht selbst klicken musst.
KVM ist nicht
QEMU. KVM ist KVM.
Das ist das, was im Linux-Kernel drin ist.
QEMU
ist ein
Emulator-Projekt,
was noch mehrere
Plattformen emulieren kann.
Zum Beispiel kannst du mit QEMU auch
ARM auf x86
64 emulieren.
Was
KVM von QEMU benutzt,
sind ein paar Bestandteile, aber
nicht die eigentliche Virtualisierung unter x86.
Es benutzt beispielsweise
das BIOS, glaube ich, zumindest.
Also die
QEMU-BIOS-Geschichten, das benutzt
glaube ich die
QEMU-SATA-Treiber
und solche Geschichten benutzen die.
Aber KVM selbst benutzt die
Linux-Virtualisierung, die Linux-x86-Virtualisierung,
nicht die QEMU-Virtualisierung.
Wir benutzen nur ein paar Teile von QEMU.
Nee, das sagt er einfach
aufgrund, dass das Video
nicht den Fokus hat da drauf.
Als
CT-Redakteur
weißt du sicherlich,
dass es ein KVM ist im Docker.
Warum sollte man das
mehr thematisieren als notwendig
für das Video?
Finde ich meinen selbstgebastelten Kleinst-Homeserver-NAS
schon echt ziemlich nice.
Ein paar Sachen haben mich auch überrascht.
Also zum Beispiel, dass man tatsächlich
sogar bei der Bedienung von Plex
einen Unterschied merkt zum alten Server
und wie viel die SSDs bringen
und der 2,5 Gigabit-Anschluss.
Etwas wenig vertrauenserweckend ist
allerdings diese Hitzigkeit.
Also ich habe beim Einsatz als Homeserver
an mehreren Tagen Dauerbetrieb
keine Probleme festgestellt.
Waren wir erstmal ab, wer bis Sommer ist,
wenn dann in der Bude
die Umgebungstemperatur 28 Grad ist.
Also ich merke das bei mir auch immer.
Ich habe ja bei mir in meinen
kleinen Serverabteil hier,
ich habe da keine Klimaanlage
und nichts drin.
Und die Geräuschkulisse
ist im Sommer
bei höherer Außentemperatur
da drin etwas höher als im Winter.
Die Lüfter drehen halt irgendwie
so 20% höher, einfach weil die Umgebungstemperatur
wärmt. Es ist nicht irgendwie
in problematischen Sphären,
aber man merkt es
anhand des Geräusches, dass das was ausmacht.
Ich bin mir halt unsicher,
ob das auch im Sommer gut geht,
die Umgebungstemperatur.
Siehste? Siehste? Genau die gleiche.
Leute, ich schwöre, ich habe das Video
vorher nicht geguckt.
War genau mein Gedanke gerade.
Also vielleicht würde ich
die M2 wieder ausbauen
und dann nur die SATA SSD nutzen.
8 Terabyte reichen ja auch
erstmal. Ich gucke mir das nochmal ein bisschen an.
Ich glaube, es ist kein Problem,
ehrlich gesagt.
Die Dinger verkraften alle ganz gut,
die Hitze.
Und
es ist nicht so,
dass es nicht so gut ist.
Und es ist nicht so, dass es nicht so gut ist.
Es bleibt, wenn man da jetzt nicht
eine halbe Stunde volle Pulle und nebenbei
was macht. Ich glaube, es bleibt im erträglichen
Rahmen. Ich denke, das ist ganz okay.
Wahrscheinlich dürfte die einfachste Abhilfe sein,
wenn es da wirklich Probleme gibt,
das Gehäuse irgendwie einem
leichten Airflow auszusetzen.
USB-Lüfter da vorstellen
oder so.
Ein Disclaimer würde ich auch gerne noch loswerden.
Wenn ihr Hardware von AliExpress bestellt,
habt ihr natürlich einige Nachteile
gegenüber dem Kauf bei
europäischen Händlern. Also A gilt natürlich
der europäische Verbraucherschutz nicht.
Also wenn ihr Probleme habt, müsst ihr hoffen, dass
AliExpress bzw. der Verkäufer
euch hilft. Und B, müsst ihr
auch bedenken, dass das ganze Thema
Rücknahmepflicht und Recycling
nicht gilt. Also europäische Händler
müssen ja alle Geräte... Das stimmt.
Juckt mich persönlich allerdings nicht.
Ich hatte nie Probleme bei AliExpress
und also
unterm Strich nie Probleme.
Ich hatte natürlich schon Probleme
mit dem Versand von AliExpress,
aber AliExpress hat das
immer zu meiner Zufriedenheit gelöst.
Und sogar besser als der
PayPal-Käuferschutz.
Deswegen kann ich sagen, ich hatte unterm Strich
nie Probleme mit AliExpress.
Und gut, ich meine,
ich würde darüber jetzt auch
nichts massiv Teures bestellen.
Also ich würde mir wahrscheinlich
nichts bestellen über AliExpress, was
in der Summe, keine Ahnung,
8.000 Euro, 20.000 Euro oder so
kostet. Das würde ich nicht machen.
Aber ich sage mal, meine
Schmerzgrenze bei AliExpress,
wäre
unter 1.000 Euro, sollte es sein.
Also über 1.000 Euro würde ich mir echt
überlegen, ob ich es bei AliExpress bestelle.
Falls es denn doch mal was ist.
Aber die meisten Sachen, die ich bei
AliExpress bestelle, die halten
sich ja auch in Grenzen.
Ich weiß nicht, was das
teuerste war. Kann ich euch aus dem Kopf
nicht sagen. Wahrscheinlich irgendwie 200, 300 Euro
oder so.
Und das wurde alles gut
gehandhabt.
Das Recycling zurücknehmen, das ist bei AliExpress
nicht der Fall. Also es gibt auf jeden Fall
auch Mini-PC. Wenn das Haus abfackelt,
haftet der Importeur. Wahrscheinlich wirst du
haften dafür. Alternativen mit N100
CPU, die ihr ganz normal jetzt
bestellen könnt. Allerdings ist die Kombination
aus 2,5 Zoll
SATA-Slot und 2,5
Gigabit Netzwerkschnittstelle echt schwierig
zu finden. Ah ja, bevor ich tschüss sage,
CT hat einen echt ziemlich
guten neuen Apparat, der heißt Haken.
TS-Fuchs sehe ich auch so. Ja,
da hätte ich auch meine Bash-Tool
dann gefunden. Da hätte ich auch meine Bedenken. Das sind so,
das ist halt so ein Batzen
Geld. Das ist nicht so
ultra viel, dass du jetzt irgendwie
Existenzprobleme danach
bekommst, wenn es weg ist. Aber es ärgert
auf jeden Fall schon richtig.
Ich würde das machen
bei AliExpress, wenn es halt wirklich ein
super nices Angebot wäre.
Exakt das, was ich haben möchte.
Vielleicht auch in einer Ausführung,
die es hier bei uns nicht gibt. Ja, vielleicht
Flashbar und das bei Amazon nicht Flashbar.
Was auch immer. Dann würde ich es trotzdem bestellen
bei AliExpress. Ich habe, wie gesagt, auch immer gute
Erfahrungen gemacht. Aber da hätte ich auch schon so ein bisschen
Bauchschmerzen, wenn denn was mit ist.
Weil eins muss man bei AliExpress
mal auch sagen, das was
da steht und das was man am Ende bekommt,
das muss im Detail nicht
immer so übereinstimmen.
Das ist genauso, wie wenn du dir
bei AliExpress mal guckst, wenn du dir
Taschenlampen bestellen willst bei AliExpress.
Da steht dann irgendwie da
eine Million Lux
Helligkeit. Ich weiß nicht, wie
auch immer die das gemessen haben, aber das ist ja
komplett unrealistisch. Die haben dann
so, was weiß ich, 8000
Lux oder so. Aber stehen halt da
eine Million. Also was da steht
und was ist nicht unbedingt
immer so
so ganz wortwörtlich zu nehmen.
Richtig.
AliExpress verkauft es nicht selbst.
Ja, so kann man es eigentlich zusammenfassen.
Ich hatte nie Probleme, aber so wirklich
richtig gut war es auch nicht immer.
Ja, das beste Beispiel
dafür ist zum Beispiel,
ist, wenn du dir einen Microcontroller
weil das ist was, was ich schon viel gemacht habe bei
AliExpress.
Microcontroller und Elektronikkram bestellst.
Also, wenn du dir einen Microcontroller bei AliExpress
bestellst, kriegst du oftmals
einen gut funktionierenden
Microcontroller, der dem entspricht,
was du gekauft hast.
Was du allerdings nicht unbedingt kriegst, ist
ein Microcontroller, der exakt
im Detail dem entspricht,
was du denkst. Zum Beispiel,
wenn du dir bei AliExpress
wir nehmen jetzt mal einen
der beliebtesten
zumindest lange Zeit
eines der beliebtesten Controller.
Wenn du dir einen Vemos
D1 Mini kaufst,
erfinderst du ganz viele bei AliExpress,
die zu 99% eben auch identisch sind zu
einem Vemos D1 Mini.
Problem ist nur, das ist ein Nachbau.
Das ist nicht zwangsläufig ein echter
D1 Mini, ein China-Chinesen-Nachbau
höchstwahrscheinlich.
Und der funktioniert auch mit den Settings,
und so alles gut aber im detail also du kriegst auf jeden fall gut was für dein
geld im detail kann sich das ein bisschen unter unterscheiden ja zum
beispiel hier auch auch relativ beliebt
esp 266 die originale note mcu als board und wenn du dir da ein
aliexpress was auch immer aliexpress wenn du dir da so eine nachbar kaufst da
kannst du probleme bekommen wenn du dich auf das originale datasheet vom
hersteller verlässt das originale datasheet vom hersteller sagt die haben
ein spannungswandler am v in input der verkraftet
und
5 bis 12 volt was enorm praktisch ist ja wenn du zum beispiel diesen micro
controller anschließen möchte soll verwenden möchte es für led steuerung
das 12 volt led ist was ein 12 volt netzteil da ist es sehr praktisch wenn
das ding 12 volt input verkraftet problem ist nur dass die nachbauten von
aliexpress viele der nachbauten von aliexpress eben kein spannungswandler am
vm haben und wenn du da dann 12 volt anschließt
oder auch nur ein bisschen mehr als fünf die das board abfackelt halt so ein
ding das muss ein paar aliexpress klasse du kriegst da gute sachen und manchmal
aber halt auch so partyheiten an die man nicht gedacht hat und das war ja auch
erst der erfahrung weil ich habe schon welche gekriegt mit mehr als 5 volt
mcu nachbauten aber trotzdem weiß dass es mit soll das würde ich auch mal kurz durch was empfiehlt er denn in die gebrauch 158.000,00 die nachbauten haben
wird so das würde ich auch mal kurz durch durch was empfiehlt er denn hier
terramaster f watt ok komm wir machen das terramaster f 4 2 1 2 vor bainers 2
gig das ist ja nix da viel zu wenig was ist da für den für den ich war also wir
werden x86 kiste doch erstaunlich ähnlich erstaunlich wir werden ja doch
eine x86 kiste lieber der anderen seite wenn es eine armkiste ist ist ja nicht
nicht pauschal schlecht die frage was dafür ein us drauf kommt ob dafür nur es
drauf media volt moment moment moment
weiche
openmedia volt gehe weg warum nicht android okay zusätzlich noch
virtualisierung das müsste doch hier die bessere wahl sein ja das frage
weiß wie gut android auf geht android auf abend cpus überhaupt gibt es das
für abend cpus nun ich habe mich hier bewusst für die virtualisierung mit
proxmox android arm entschieden und demnach mit openmedia volt
da ihr gerade was die hauptkomponente also proxmox hier angeht wesentlich mehr
möglichkeiten das problem ist warum warum nicht android ist ganz einfach
beantwortet weil android darauf nicht läuft was er hatte ein i3 im video okay
dann würde ich das tatsächlich nehmen wenn es keine arm cpu ist was ist denn
jetzt da steht drin dass eine arm cpu ist mich veräppeln das haben wir gerade vor
zwei minuten geguckt vielleicht dann eher das ja keine ahnung also ich sehe es da
hat das denn gibt es das denn mit x86 cpu
da ist kein da ist kein idr oder so drin hat irgendwas anderes keine ahnung
hardware okay erst mal gucken was du jetzt an welche haupt ihr braucht ja
logischerweise ein terra master das ihr könnt auch andere modelle nehmen als das
dass ich hier zeige die funktionalität ist bei vielen modellen ach guck mal das
ist ein f-44 24
als falsche verlinkt und amazon ist einfach wieder ultra pp wahrscheinlich
hier hat die man nicht so eine shopping seite irgendwie product es ist ja mal
wieder super super wird wo kann man das kaufen überhaupt wow ok jetzt kommt aber
ein preis ist die region da kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten wie sind sie
nicht dass da ist kein geiz als chat gedenkt wieder mit exzellent ok das hat
man eben nicht gefunden ja da ist das ist im prinzip dass ja
da muss man preislich schon gucken dass das klingt nach einer sinnvolle das
klingt tatsächlich einer sinnvollen hardware
so kommen fünf points
4 4 base und cpu was ist drin in 95 quad core was was soll was soll das sein
alter alter lake also aus und low power ding was hat er denn hier drin
ich habe euch natürlich dieses modell dass ich hier verwende auch mit den zwei cpu ausführungen
unten er ist grundsätzlich verlinkt dann braucht
ihr natürlich noch logischer was ist denn jetzt drinnen zwei hd dauer
ich weiß gar nicht ja aber das muss ich sagen das sieht tatsächlich auch nicht nach einem
schlechten case aus weil ich mag für netzwerk storage solche wechselrahmen systeme
einfach praktisch ist und man kommt schön dran ich habe so ein hp microserver der hat noch mal eine
ich habe so ein hp microserver der hat noch mal eine
ganze ecke mehr cpu power als so ein ding die brauche ich aber eigentlich gar
ganze ecke mehr cpu power als so ein ding die brauche ich aber eigentlich gar nicht so wirklich
nicht so wirklich
nicht so wirklich und da ist es ein bisschen umständlicher die
und da ist es ein bisschen umständlicher die
und da ist es ein bisschen umständlicher die platten rein auszukriegen haben zwar auch
platten rein auszukriegen haben zwar auch
platten rein auszukriegen haben zwar auch so einen rahmen dafür wo man nicht
so einen rahmen dafür wo man nicht
so einen rahmen dafür wo man nicht schön rein raus aber ist nicht so schön
schön rein raus aber ist nicht so schön
schön rein raus aber ist nicht so schön wie wenn du einfach vorne das ganze
wie wenn du einfach vorne das ganze
wechseln kannst.
Was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde,
hat das Gehäuse irgendwie die Möglichkeiten,
LED-Anzeige
an den Wechsel
vorne zu machen?
Wofür
sind die LEDs? Sind die einfach
nur für den
Betrieb
oder können die angesteuert werden
für Fehler?
Weil ansonsten musst du die
auf jeden Fall hier vorne mit
so einem Etikett oder so draufschreiben, die
Seriennummer von den Platten, die drin sind, dass du später
erkennst, welche Platte du austauschen
musst, wenn was kaputt geht.
Ja, der Vorteil gegenüber einem Desktop,
einem alten, richtig alten Desktop,
ist auf jeden Fall der Stromverbrauch.
Und was bei
diesen Nassgehäusen halt auch praktisch ist,
du kommst halt einfach an die Platten dran, was bei
normalen PC-Gehäusen
nicht der Fall ist.
Ansonsten, die sind seit
Jahren schon
so leistungsstark,
normale PCs, dass du damit
easy 2,5 Gig
Saturated kriegst
und du hast auch genug PC-Express
Steckplätze, um Netzwerkkarten
und alles reinzupappen. Also, all der PC
hat auch seine Vorteile.
Größter Nachteil
ist tatsächlich der Stromverbrauch.
Und dass es nicht so schön ist, an die Platten dran zu kommen.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Stupsi, die älteste Katze
der... Ja, genau. Cat-Content.
Das muss jetzt sein.
Excellent.
Sie hat das ganz große losgezogen.
Ihren Lebensabend verbringt
die betagte Katze in ihrem
eigenen Zimmer in Altötting.
Altöttingen? Das muss jetzt so sein, denn die
vermutlich älteste Miete der Welt...
Wisst ihr, das ist eine Sache, die mag
ich an alten Katzen. Die sind so super
entspannt. Die hängen
immer rum
und
sind einfach
sehr gechillt, ja.
Hat inzwischen doch einige
Wehwehchen.
Blind und taub. Blind und taub.
Kriegt nix halt.
Wie gesagt, ich hatte ja auch schon einige
Katzen, die ein bisschen älter waren.
Unter anderem
hier Chico. Hier unten.
Die da. Chico ist...
Ich weiß es gar nicht, wie alt die geworden ist. Am Ende jetzt 14
oder 15 oder so. 14?
Irgendwie 13, 14, 15.
Ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Das ist jetzt noch
nicht super alt
für Katzen, aber auch schon älter.
Und die hat halt auch...
Die hat auch Probleme. Und die anderen auch.
Am gewissen Alter.
Und hat wenig Zehen.
Aber so im großen
Alten geht es ihr eigentlich ganz gut.
Umgerechnet etwa 130
Menschenjahre hat Stupsi
auf dem Katzenbuckel.
Auch deshalb wird sie nach Strich und Faden
verwöhnt. Ja, was eine Feine.
Als Marina Takovic vor einiger
Zeit mit ihrer Mutter alte Fotos
ansieht, stellen beide
überrascht fest, dass die
Katze vor vielen Jahren...
Die war schon immer da.
... bereits auf dem Bauernhof
lebte. Sie beginnen nachzurechnen.
Ja, Chico gibt
das seit Dezember nicht mehr.
... mit Stupsi ist auf den Februar
1995 datiert.
Das heißt, sie muss im...
Warum krabbeln da irgendwelche Spinnen unter den Fotos rum?
Das finde ich...
Das ist irgendeine Mücke, die gelandet ist.
Das fand ich jetzt irritierend.
... datiert. Das heißt, sie muss im Herbst
1994 auf die Welt
gekommen sein.
Da war ihre Mama früher da.
Antike Katze.
Die Stupsi war im alten
Ägypten schon am Start.
Die Geschwister haben wir hergegeben.
Und dann ist sie so
brav, stark, Hofkatz geworden.
In Bayern immer. Immer unauffällig, aber immer da.
Vor Weihnachten dann der Schock.
Die alte Stupsi war plötzlich
verschwunden. Es wird das Schlimmste
befürchtet. Doch die
Katzenseniorin sitzt verwirrt auf
der Straße und landet im Tierheim.
Marina entdeckt sie auf
Facebook.
Und holt sie zu sich.
Im Haus gibt es genügend andere
tierische Verstärkung.
Aber Stupsi liegt ihren Besitzern
besonders am Herzen.
Weil sie war früher schon immer überall dabei.
Sie hat uns im Garten begleitet.
Sie ist einmal mit spazieren gegangen.
Ja.
Und sie war sehr agil, als die Maus
angegangen ist. Sie hat fleißig gefangen
und auch fleißig hergezockt. Und hat sich
mit dem Matz gefreut. Ja. Geht halt jetzt leider
nicht mehr so.
Einen amtlichen Beweis dafür, dass Stupsi die älteste Katze der Welt ist, ist die Katze, die die älteste Katze der Welt ist.
Einen amtlichen Beweis dafür, dass Stupsi die älteste Katze der Welt ist.
gibt es nicht.
Aber der Rekord ist ihrer Familie gar nicht so wichtig.
Sie darf da in dem Zimmer mit Heizung wohnen.
Und ...
Ja, Heizung ist das Beste.
Kleine Aufmerksamkeit, wie eben immer so ein Schmusekissen,
das mit Baldrian getränkt ist.
Das macht es dann schon ein bisschen schöner.
Bei Baldrian flippt es aus.
Wenn es dann noch ein bisschen Freude hat.
Ein bisschen Sonnenlicht auf alte Knochen
kann dabei nicht schaden.
Was haben wir denn jetzt?
Was lohnt sich Schädlings...
Oh, nee, das wird eklig, Leute.
Ich weiß nicht.
Nee, das kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
Wobei Kakerlaken schocken mich nicht so sehr.
Was verdient man als Schädling?
Wahrscheinlich nicht genug.
nicht genug, dass ich das machen würde.
Also, man darf auf jeden Fall keinen Ekel haben vor Schädlingen.
Das ist natürlich der Hauptpunkt.
Ja.
Ja, im Freundeskreis kann man da schon von sagen.
schon ein paar Witze, du Rattenfänger. Ich habe da echt meinen Weg gefunden. Ich kann
mir jetzt auch vorstellen, das bis zum Rentenalter zu machen.
Hallo, ich bin Arthirn, bin 27 Jahre alt, bin Schädlingsbekämpfer und komme aus Baden-Württemberg.
Ich bin immer monatlich da und das Monitoring machen wir heute. Muss kontrolliert werden,
dass halt erstmal Nagios installieren, keine Schädlinge auftreten. Da sind mehrere Fallen
und da habe ich Giftköder dabei oder auch andere Köder. Dann gucken wir nach, ob da
jetzt ein Befall feststeht oder nicht. Okay, wir würden jetzt einmal reingehen zu den Kunden.
Oh, alles klar. Toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss, toss. Servus. Hallo. Hallo, alles gut?
Es war wieder soweit. Keine besondere Auffälligkeit. Okay, perfekt. Das hört man immer gerne.
Okay, wir würden jetzt einmal runtergehen. Wir im Keller haben hier Fallen installiert.
Hier ist die erste Falle. Der erste Monitor, sagen wir dazu. Das sieht ein bisschen wie bei mir im Keller aus.
Als Fachbegriff. Und das ist eine Mottenfalle. Lebensmittelbetriebe kommen das öfter mal vor,
Mehlmotten vor allem. Klar, wenn Mehl in der Nähe ist, da könnten jetzt Motten auftreten.
Aber hier ist jetzt zum Beispiel gar nichts. Es ist so, bei jedem Monitor haben wir hier unseren Scanner
und da haben wir so ein eigenes Programm. Und dann schreiben wir jetzt halt rein, kein Befall festgestellt.
Wäre da jetzt ein Befall, dann schreiben wir natürlich Befall, so und so viele Motten.
Also vier oder fünf Motten. Und welche Motte? Ich habe meistens Monitoring-Kunden. Das ist ja monatlich.
Da ist meistens schon ein Fixtermin. Also, keine Ahnung, am 15. April muss ich da hin, am 10. Mai muss ich da hin.
Das ist eigentlich unser Hauptgeschäft. Beobachten, kontrollieren, ob was auftreten könnte.
Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass wir zum Kunden gehen und es ist akut was. Kann natürlich auch sein.
Und dann leiten wir eine Bekämpfung ein. Also, hier ist ein Schabenmonitor. Aha.
Also, hier ist ein Schabenmonitor. Aha.
Da befindet sich jetzt zum Beispiel ein Jungtier von einer deutschen Schabe drauf. Genau.
Also, wird...
Ah! Also quasi eine Baby-Kakerlake sozusagen.
...wahrscheinlich hier die Mutter noch rumlaufen.
Und jetzt schaue ich nochmal in der Ecke, ob da noch andere Merkmale sein könnten, ob hier Schaben sind.
Jetzt zum Beispiel in der Ecke sind auf jeden Fall noch tote Schaben.
Das Problem ist, das kann ich leider nicht verschieben hier.
Aber mit dem...
...können wir da leider nicht ran.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall weg, weil auch wenn eine Kontrolle hier ist vom Gesundheitsamt oder anderen, kommt das nicht so gut.
Aber später gehe ich mit dem Chef nochmal hierher und schaue auf jeden Fall nach.
Hier zum Beispiel ist auch der perfekte Hotspot, dass Schaben sich auffallen können, weil hier ist warm und feucht.
Hier fühlen die sich auf jeden Fall pudelwohl.
Da hat sich mein Verdacht auf jeden Fall bestätigt.
Ich handel jetzt auf jeden Fall.
Ich gehe jetzt nochmal zum Auto und hole mein Schabengel und meine Fallen und dann werden wir das auf jeden Fall bekämpfen können.
Das ist so ein bestimmter Wirkstoff, der wirkt halt gegen Schaben, dass sie sterben.
Die fressen das und dann bringen die das halt ins Nest und dann sterben alle, weil die Kannibalen sind.
Okay, dann würden wir wieder reingehen.
Sprich, die fressen alles.
Sie fressen sich untereinander auch.
Da habe ich hier meine Schabengelpistole, nennt sich die.
Also, der englische Fachbegriff ist Baitgun.
Aber wir sagen ungarnsprachig Schabenpistole.
Natürlich meine Handschuhe anziehen.
Dadurch, dass wir hier Schaben in dem Monitor gesehen wurden, werde ich jetzt überall hier...
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine Heißkleber.
Heißkleber.
Schabengelpunkte setzen.
Eins vor Harry, ja.
An diesem Hotspot.
Genau, so kleine Punkte.
Für die Schaben ist das jetzt ungefähr so wie...
Nix wie weg.
Kennt man fast gar nicht.
Die mache ich jetzt überall.
Einmal hier rein, wo sich Schaben gerne aufhalten.
Also, hier habe ich letztes Mal schon so eine Papierfalle für Schaben aufgestellt.
Und siehe da, ist einiges los.
Dann setze ich mal hier wieder ein paar Gelpunkte.
In alten Häusern ist öfter mal...
Kann ein Schabenbefall entstehen, weil halt alles so alt gebaut ist.
Also, ich denke eher, das liegt an den Baulichtmängeln.
An der Hygiene liegt es hier zum Beispiel gar nicht.
Wenn man die Ausbund abschießt, kann man eigentlich so gut wie alles töten.
Außer was natürlich unter Artenschutz steht, das ist verboten.
Aber sonst ist man erlaubt, jedes Schädling...
Das machen wir nur, wenn die Kamera nicht dabei ist.
...zu bekämpfen.
Das ist jetzt die letzte Falle.
Genau, eine Rattenbox auf dem Balkon.
Wenn jetzt der Köder angefressen wäre.
Also, dann ist auf jeden Fall Rattenbefall.
Hier ist jetzt nicht so der Fall.
Perfekt, also gehe ich nicht davon aus, dass hier Ratten sind.
Da schreibe ich dann einfach in mein System rein, kein Befall.
Mein konkreter Auftrag ist, den Kunden hier zu beraten, ob irgendwelche Mängel sind,
oder hygienische Mängel, bauliche Mängel, was sie vielleicht verbessern könnten,
dass keine Schädlinge mehr hier auftreten.
Und natürlich, dadurch, dass sie auch hier überall unsere Fallen und Systeme aufgestellt haben,
da schaue ich dann, ob da was sein könnte oder nicht.
Also, ich bin zum Monitoring hier.
Aber natürlich, wenn sowas anfällt, dass da jetzt auf den Fallen was ist, dann muss man halt handeln.
Und das haben wir auch so abgemacht, dass ich dann immer handel.
Okay, dann würden wir kurz runtergehen.
Schabencheck.
Das war hinten in der Ecke, aber ich bin da dran gekommen.
Die müssen wir vorziehen wieder.
Das wäre gut, wenn wir die vielleicht vorziehen könnten.
Sind die Papierpresse dann heute Nachmittag vor?
Ja.
Okay, machen wir.
Und da brauchen wir auch ein paar Leute mit Muckis, weil die ist ziemlich schwer.
Und dann ziehen wir sie vor und gucken, da gehen wir.
Dann bräuchte ich gerade wie immer hier die Unterschrift im weißen Feld.
Diese Dinger, ne?
Da musst du ja auch teilweise unterschreiben, wenn die Post vorbeikommt.
Da drauf sieht meine Unterschrift null aus, wie meine Unterschrift auf diesen Dingern.
Alles klar.
Bis dann.
Dankeschön.
Ciao.
Manchmal fehlen ganze Striche und so.
Kann auch mal sein, dass man länger im Auto ist.
Einmal eine gute zwei, drei Stunden hin und zwei, drei Stunden zurück.
Das ist immer unterschiedlich.
Aber heute ist es zum Beispiel so, dass wir echt alles in derselben Stadt haben.
Das passt halt gut.
Ich habe in Mannheim erstmal die mittlere Reife abgeschlossen.
Dann habe ich erstmal eine Ausbildung angefangen zur Fachkraft für Lagerlogistik.
Habe die aber nach zwei Jahren abgebrochen.
Und danach habe ich mal eine Ausbildung zum Hotelfachmann ausgeschlossen.
Das habe ich ausprobiert.
Das habe ich auch abgebrochen.
Und dann habe ich auch eine Ausbildungsmesse, den Beruf, wo ich jetzt ausübe, kennengelernt.
Schädlingsbekämpfer.
Und habe dort drei Jahre die Ausbildung gemacht.
Guck mal.
Der hat einfach drei Aus...
Ach nee, hier abgebrochen, abgebrochen.
Wo hat der einfach dreimal drei Ausbildungen gemacht?
Ausübe, kennengelernt, Schädlingsbekämpfer.
Und habe dort drei Jahre die Ausbildung gemacht.
Weil wenn man drei Ausbildungen verkackt hat, dann will sich keiner mehr.
Deswegen war der Druck dann schon höher.
Aber keine Ahnung, ich habe mich viel mehr wertgeschätzt gefühlt.
Die Leute waren viel glücklicher.
Man braucht halt einfach manchmal eine Weile, bis man das gefunden hat, was einem Bock macht.
Und anscheinend ist es bei ihm Schädlingsbekämpfer.
Wir sehen das in Deutschland, finde ich, an vielen Stellen einfach viel zu kritisch.
Vielmehr mal gelobt.
Die haben einen vielmehr einfach...
Die Personalabteilung wieder irgendwelche Sachen reinfantasieren.
... in der Lagerlogistik oder Hotelbranche.
Jetzt fahren wir zum zweiten Kunden heute.
Da wird auch wieder Monitoring durchgeführt.
Da sind wir monatlich.
Interessant wird halt...
Letzten Monat war ich da und da war in der Reinigungsmaschine...
... da waren Schaben, also Kakerlaken.
Muss ich mal schauen, ob die immer noch dort sind.
Hier war ein sehr starker Befall.
Im Februar.
Frage ist auch, ob das wieder deutsche Kakerlaken sind.
Wundert mich das oder ich bin auch glücklich, dass es jetzt weniger geworden ist.
Weil da waren die ganzen Fallen richtig voll.
Und da sind dann auch wirklich Schaben auch rausgesprungen.
Also die hat man direkt gesehen.
Akut.
Aber es scheint sich erledigt zu haben.
Also es sieht gut aus.
Wir haben ja keinen sozialen Beruf.
Aber irgendwie ist es ja auch ein bisschen sozial, weil wir helfen den Leuten.
Die Leute, die diese Produkte bekommen, sind glücklich.
Das kannst du dann zu jeder Dienstleistung sagen.
Wo Leute zu dir kommen und was haben wollen.
Ich bin ja auch schon ein bisschen sozial.
Ich habe seinen Internetanschluss repariert.
Vorne ist er auch sehr sozial.
Also das macht mich echt glücklich.
Mittagspause.
Früher bin ich öfter mal zum Bäcker gegangen.
Ich habe auch übelst Hunger.
Ich muss gleich was füttern.
Aber ich habe einfach gemerkt, es geht sehr ins Geld.
Das stimmt wohl.
Deswegen mache ich mir lieber was selber.
Ist auch gesünder.
Das sieht aus wie...
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie das, was ihr abends mittlerweile auch futtert.
Seit einer Weile.
Bananen oder irgendwelche Obstzinger mit Haferflocken dabei.
Ein bisschen Quark.
Das macht gut satt.
Und verträgt man gut auf abends.
Futter irgendwas.
Das ist besser.
Okay, Mittagspause ist jetzt zu Ende.
Wir haben 13 Uhr.
Ich fahre jetzt zum nächsten Kunden.
Zum nächsten Bäcker.
Mal gucken, was mich da erwartet.
Letzte Stunde das Ding gefuttert.
Da wurde mal eine Maus gesichtet vor längerer Zeit.
Und da wollen wir so Elektrofall installieren.
Und wir kriegen dann eine Benachrichtigung
auf unser Programm, wenn da eine Maus drin ist.
Smart.
Smart Traps.
IOT-Mausefall.
Hier ist ein Müllraum.
Und da ist hier eine Maus umgesprungen.
Da war ganz hinten noch älterer Mäusekot.
Der ist schon getrocknet aber.
Und jetzt würde ich halt hier die neuen Funkfallen ausprobieren.
Es gibt schon immer die klassischen Tunnelfallen.
Mit zwei Schlagfallen integriert.
Aber jetzt ist es so, die funktionieren mit Funk.
Machen wir hier direkt mal eine.
Und hier könnte ich echt eine aufhalten.
Dann installiert man so Antennen für den Funk,
dass man einen guten Empfang hat.
Und da kommt dann wahrscheinlich eine SIM-Karte oder so rein.
Das macht dann alles noch einfacher.
Man muss nicht mehr jeden Tag hierher kommen und kontrollieren.
Und der Kunde auch nicht selbst.
Man kann dann einfach die Benachrichtigung bekommen.
Und man sieht dann, wenn man was findet, geht es vorbei.
Also ich verdiene 3.000 Euro brutto monatlich.
Bekomme 2.050 Euro netto raus.
Und dann bekomme ich noch 500 Euro ohne Abschläge.
Urlaubsgeld im Jahr.
Und nach Hause komme ich dann meistens wie jetzt zwischen 16 und 17 Uhr.
Meistens höre ich meinen Kunden so um 16 Uhr auf.
Und dann ist halt das Problem mit dem Verkehr.
Kann sein, dass ich dann gut durchkomme und bin um 17 Uhr zu Hause.
Aber kann auch sein, dass es halt ein Unfall war oder der Feierabendverkehr so schlimm,
dass ich dann erst um 18 Uhr, 18.30 Uhr mal tue.
Oh, das suckt.
Leider kann man das halt schlecht Homeoffice-technisch ausüben.
Wenn zwar alles elektronisch ist und man nur noch auf die Fallen gucken muss,
vielleicht ab und zu.
Wichtig ist immer natürlich, die Schuhe auszuziehen.
Gerade wenn so ein Schabenauftrag wie heute war mit Kakerlaken.
Weil nicht, dass man die in die Wohnung reinschleppt.
Dann ziehe ich die Schuhe immer vor der Tür aus.
Wie war dein Tag?
Ja, war gut. Viele Kakerlaken heute wieder.
Also hier wohne ich auf 61 Quadratmeter.
Und ich bezahle 600 Euro monatlich Warm-Miete.
Kakerlaken.
Ja.
Das ist so.
Ich kann mich, also ich hatte nie irgendwo Kakerlaken.
Das Einzige, wo ich mich daran erinnern kann,
weil ich es super eklig fand, wo ich klein war.
Da waren wir mal im Urlaub irgendwo in Spanien oder so.
Und in der Wohnung, die wir dort hatten, in diesem Bungalow,
gab es Kakerlaken.
Das war eklig.
Da haben wir dann auch, glaube ich, irgendwann neun.
Ich kann mich noch ganz dunkel daran erinnern.
Ich gehe mir am Morgen, ich gehe mir essen.
Peruanisch.
Ich habe auch sehr Hunger.
Ich freue mich schon.
Ja.
Das sieht nicht aus wie die Tür, die nach draußen geht.
Das sieht, weil das so dunkel ist.
Das sieht aus, als gehen die jetzt gerade in irgendeine Abstellkammer, oder?
Ich gehe mir am Morgen, ich gehe mir essen.
So, okay.
Lass mal kurz in die Abstellkammer rein.
Ich mache die Tür zu.
Ich habe auch sehr Hunger.
Ich freue mich schon.
Ja.
Ich habe mein Auto 2020 gekauft.
Und das hat 12.000 Euro gekostet.
Aber ich zahle es monatlich mit 250 Euro ab.
Bis 2025.
Also wir mögen es immer zu reisen und woanders hinzugehen.
Wir wohnen halt in der Pampa.
Und da muss man halt immer auf weite Wege gehen,
um was Schönes zu erleben oder Cooles.
Also wir sparen gerade für die Peru-Reise im August.
Wir fliegen nämlich im August nach Peru, in ihr Heimatland,
wie man unschwer erkennen kann.
Und da gehen wir auch nach Bolivia noch,
auf eine Hochzeit von Freunden von Stuttgart.
Und das Ganze kostet halt 5.000 Euro für beide insgesamt.
Und da müssen wir halt viel sparen.
Ich habe da echt meinen Weg gefunden.
Ich kann mir das auch vorstellen, noch bis zum Rentenalter zu machen.
Der Anzeigen-Hauptmeister, den haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
Gibt es das?
Gibt es da eigentlich einen zweiten Teil mittlerweile von?
Ja, so wirklich reich wirst du als Schädlingsbekämpfer ja nicht.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall zu wenig für das,
dass ich sowas ekliges machen würde.
Er ist heute bei Monte im Stream.
Der Anzeigen-Hauptmeister persönlich.
Ja, 250 Euro Überschuss ist schon knapp.
Wobei man sagen muss, Lifestyle ist schon vorher weg.
Essen und so ist schon alles weg.
Also wirklich, dann, ja.
Also auf so eklige Sachen hätte ich eh keinen Bock.
Da müssten die mir deutlich mehr bezahlen.
Aber gut, dass es Leute gibt, die das machen.
So, das war's von mir.
Ich hoffe, ihr hattet Spaß.
Die das nicht ekelt.
Zu begleiten als Schädlingsbekämpfer.
Wenn ihr wollt, schaut euch nochmal hier den Müllmann an.
Und hier den Anlagenmechaniker.
Ciao, macht's gut.
See you.
Ja, gut, dass es Leute gibt, die das machen.
Das wäre echt nichts für mich.
Ich meine, von Kakerlaken und so, das ekelt mich jetzt nicht so.
Aber Bock hätte ich da nicht drauf.
Mäuse habe ich auch keine Probleme.
Aber es gibt genug andere Sachen, die ich eklig finde.
Wo du dich als Schädlingsbekämpfer auch mit auseinandersetzen musst, ja.
OpenWRT auf KVM, but why?
AlexiBexi, das ist so ein Channel, den kann ich mir einfach nicht angucken.
Obwohl man ja eigentlich vermuten würde, dass er vom Content her ein bisschen was macht,
was mich durchaus interessieren könnte.
Aber ich kann mir das nicht angucken.
Das ist immer so anstrengend zu schauen.
Downsizing.
Ja, endlich mal einer, der was Sinnvolles macht.
Endlich mal einer, der was Sinnvolles macht.
Aufwärts.
Oversized Shit einfach ein bisschen abbauen.
Ja, das ist die Frage, die ich bei so gut wie jedem Homelab-Video stelle.
Was machen die eigentlich damit?
Bei TechnoTim habe ich es bis heute nicht verstanden, was er darauf macht.
Außer Management für das Management für das Management.
Und dann im Endeffekt ein Dashboard.
Wir machen kein OpenWRT heute.
Gucken uns OpenObserve an als Monitoring für daheim.
Oder generell als Monitoring.
Mal gucken, ob das was taugt.
Das Downsizing macht durchaus Sinn.
Ich meine außer, man hat halt wirklich handfeste Gründe, Argumente dafür, dass man sagt, ey,
ich brauche hier oben mindestens mal 5 Server und irgendwie 3 NUCs oder was das ist.
Wo sonst?
Die meisten werden es nicht brauchen.
Ich gebe ja zu, ich verstehe dieses, ich kenne das auch.
Ich gebe ja zu, ich verstehe dieses, ich kenne dieses auch.
Ich glaube, dass das so einen gewissen haben wollen Faktor hat.
Ich meine, ich bin ja schon nicht normal aus Sicht der meisten Leute mit meinem Serverraum.
Aber da ist viel, viel weniger drin, als das, was man in diesen Videos immer sieht.
Da steht ein HP Microserver drin, den habe ich jetzt auch schon eine Weile.
Ein 10-Gig-Switch.
3D-Drucker.
Mein ganzes oder meiste vom Werkzeug.
Router.
Und die Fritzbox.
Das war es.
Gibt es ein paar Videos bei mir auf YouTube.
Ich müsste mal wieder, das muss ich mir mal aufräumen.
Serverraum-Update-Video.
Hast du den ZigBee-Stick schon geflasht?
Ja, habe ich gemacht.
Sogar im Stream.
Aber wenn du so fragst, vermute ich mal, du warst nicht dabei.
Das war easy, war das.
Hier.
Also, der ZigBee-Stick, das war wirklich...
Easy as fuck.
Easy.
Ja, da.
Guck.
Von der, von der Gesamtheit.
Ja, da.
Guck.
Von der, von der gesamten Sache habe ich 30 Minuten den Stick geflasht.
Den Rest habe ich irgendwie, weil ich das andere Zeug geguckt und ich habe was gegessen
dabei.
Eine Smart-Home-Tour.
Ja.
Wollte ich.
Link, please.
Geh ins Archiv.
Da.
Archiv.
Worts.
Klick das an.
Gibt es sogar einen Link zum Archiv?
Moment.
Geht das noch?
Ist das noch richtig?
Ja.
Es redirected.
Ah.
Wort redirect- Ach guck mal.
Wir haben sogar einen Link zum Youtube-Channel.
Super Projekt.
Moment.
Es gibt tatsächlich mal Kommentare in diesem Watchannel.
Warte Minute.
Wer?
Alter.
Modgis.
Ihr seid ja sowas von high IQ.
Sind das Auto, sind das Auto Generated Captions?
Nee, nicht Captions, Auto Generated Chapters?
Oder werden die wirklich von Hand
generated von euch, ey?
Ja, nice, dass man sich da so viel Mühe macht.
Das Archiv
ist eh biggest high IQ
Sache überhaupt.
Was machen die per Hand?
Meine Güte, ey.
Richtige, schlaue,
massive, big brain mods.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das
automatisch erkennt, es geht weiter mit
Programmieren. Das glaube ich nicht.
Wie dem auch sei, Leute, heute Mittag
höchstwahrscheinlich, gucken wir uns
Open Observe an, weil es mich persönlich interessiert.
Wir werden auch mal ein bisschen streamen.
Ich geh jetzt auf, ich geh jetzt was futtern.
Ach ja, dreimal dürft ihr raten, was es heute gibt.
Es ist nicht Lachs.
Es ist nicht Nudel mit Lachs, es ist Spaghetti Bolognese.
Die übliche
Sonntagmittag
Sache.
Wir sehen uns später.
Macht's gut, bis dann.
See you.